yesterday was pretty crazy we got
swatted while we were live on the air we
do have uh some updates for you and so
in lieu of the standard you know
several minute intro i'm just gonna say
welcome to the show uh we're gonna do an
update on the swatting we've got a bunch
of stories for you i've spoken with some
individuals security we think we may
know what happened we'll get into all
that joining us today is chris carr
executive editor at timcast.com thanks
for having me man happy to be here
absolutely our uh guest schedule today
was uh michael graves formerly of the
misfits unfortunately couldn't make it
weather was really bad the roads are all
you know pretty bad it's unfortunate
because it's not that much snow but
we're in the middle of nowhere so we got
luke yep lots of crazy news to get into
first of all shouts out to everyone in
the cast beanie castle who was doing the
workout boot camp training shouts out
especially to linda she's punching the
punching bag so aggressively i thought
it was going to fly across the room i
was like just imagine it's the mean
commenters and man she let it have it
anyway my church of fear shirt just came
in and it's nicely showing a great karen
with a mask face shield and gloves
praying of course to the corporate
overlords on the boob tube you could get
yours exclusively on
thebestpoliticoshirts.com and because
you do i'm here thanks for having me
what's up everybody ian crossland over
here glad to be here check me out
eatoncrossline.net if you ever wanna and
i'll uh see you in a bit i am also here
i'm wearing my step on snake and find
out t-shirt you can't see the whole
thing which makes me really sad but i am
wearing it i'm very excited about it
it's gorgeous love it get yours before
we get started we have an awesome
sponsor it's virtual shield go to
surfinginternetsafe.com and you can get
a virtual private network service 50 off
for life and it's 50 off on all add-ons
and 77 off of the service itself a
virtual private network service it's a
basic layer of security for you while
you're surfing the internet and let me
tell you exactly why you want to you
want something like this
we are learning right now that in the
january 6 committee the they're
subpoenaing uh they're getting access to
people's private text messages simply by
going to the phone company and say and
saying give me their text messages and
they're handing them right over if you
use an encryption service if you use
some kind of virtual private network you
protect yourself from prying eyes if the
government wants access to your stuff
they can get a warrant but if you're
sending all of your data through a
third-party company well they've got
your data too so go to surfing internet
safe
again you will get 50 off for life on
the on all add-ons 77 off on the service
it's 2.50 per month and a shout out to
virtual shield they're our first sponsor
they've been here since the beginning
it's a great service and we really do
appreciate their support throughout the
past couple of years i've been doing
this for several years and they've been
there the entire way uh support
companies that support us and the work
we do so again if you want a virtual
private network you can check out
surfinginternetsafe.com don't forget go
to timcast.com become a member and help
support our work no members only
segments today we do those monday
through thursday but we do have a green
room episode up and i believe it's with
marjorie taylor green so behind the
scenes when she shows up and it shows
all of us getting ready for the show and
uh don't forget to like this video
subscribe to this channel share the show
with your friends if you really do want
to support our work uh let's just let's
just do this look we've got news about
scotus we've got um you know news about
uh this new study on the vaccines we got
a clip up from joe rogan but uh i hate
to do this and and we didn't initially
want to that's why we we we titled this
video just like a normal news day
but there's a lot of questions around
the swatting and we do have some
developments i've made some phone calls
so
for those that aren't familiar last
night during the show we got swatted and
that means someone called the police and
claimed there was an active shooter on
the property and that people had been
hurt
during the show luke was talking and you
can see an officer walk past the camera
and then walk out and it seems to go
very quickly i walk out of the room and
then uh after we realized what happened
you know lydia's like look we got
swatted i get up and i go talk to the
cop there were two out there and we come
back a lot of people
didn't get the full picture from that
they believed there was just a couple
cops who walked in waved and left there
were eight cops that i ended up uh i saw
i think i saw five downstairs when i
went back out and said what was going on
and asked them politely to leave and
then there were also state troopers and
there was another jurisdiction i think a
sheriff's department
they were all asked politely to leave i
said i don't want you here without a
warrant so uh as to what happened we
don't know who did it we do have a
couple different firms legal firms
filing everything and we're getting into
high gear to figure out what we can
preserve body camera footage the 911
call people have already released the
the the police radio uh calls a couple
of them
and what i can say is i uh there were a
few theories as to what happened and why
we got swatted now i'm sure whoever did
it it's probably listening i don't know
what their intention was some people
were saying it's just it's the internet
it's trolls it's what happens perhaps
some people were thinking that it's
related to some trolling that's been
going on but uh one of the theories that
we had to discuss was whether or not it
was related to marjorie taylor green's
appearance on the show i did mention it
the other day
and after the show
i didn't want to you know uh contact her
team and and drag her into something she
was here the day before on the fifth
not on not the day we got we got swatted
but you know luke mentioned it's
probably a good idea for security
reasons just to let people know like hey
this happened and i can't speak for
marjorie taylor green and what her
opinion of this is but what was conveyed
to me
is that she's been receiving a large
amount of death threats as of the sixth
and that leads me to believe that what
happened to us was directly related to
us hosting her i don't know for sure i'm
not saying it's a guarantee i'm not
saying i believe 100 percent i'm saying
it seems probable and the reason is
we film these live episodes
we start at 8pm we end at 10. at 10 when
we end the live stream is when youtube
says it's published and it sends out
notifications slowly to a bunch of
people that means for a lot of people
you'll wake up in the morning and get a
notification you know tim cast irelle
with guest marjorie taylor green
on this day the morning of january 6
when people are getting this
notification that we hosted her that's
the day she was getting slammed with
death threats
so i don't think it's a coincidence then
that on that same day that she's getting
death threats we also get swatted and it
may be because some people either the
individual mistakenly thought we were
currently hosting her on the show or it
was just they saw the show the
notification or just someone mentioned
it and they said screw these people and
they end up swatting us ultimately we
have no idea why it happened but i think
that seems to be the most likely
i don't know i don't know for sure and i
don't want to um
i i don't know i don't want to make it
seem like we're saying it's def it's
definitive we just don't know but that
seems likely and uh i don't know if you
guys wanted to add anything and well you
know of course this is a very serious
matter we were very lucky that one of
our employees was outside and prevented
the swatting prevent and prevented the
raid um
i don't know if the officer was waiting
for backup or just waiting to assess the
situation waiting for backup but if you
okay but but you know if the officer was
waiting to assess the situation that was
the right move to to make there and it
prevented a lot of people from getting
hurt so shouts out to all the employees
that were out there that are
professional that didn't panic didn't
freak out and also started filming the
police right away when they entered here
there's you know a lot of questions
surrounding that as well but it was
three different jurisdictions a large
number of police officers we couldn't
even count all the police cars that were
here so this was a major incident and
luckily uh it didn't get escalated and
uh we got a number of things at play and
we're going to do our best to find out
what's going on here there were also
some of our staff reported police
vehicles driving down the road back and
forth so aside from the eight or however
many vehicles were in the driveway
and then there were i believe at least
eight officers walking around maybe more
there are actually other officers
driving around because this is what
people need to realize about this so um
i can't give too much information away
because there's an ongoing investigation
but
this is we're very close to washington
dc
the people who live in this area
many of them are
politicos political lawyers um people
who work in uh they work in politics
they work in dc right
so we're about an hour west of
washington dc
this area of the tri-state which is
virginia maryland and west virginia and
the harpers ferry area
has a ton
of dc commuters these people are fairly
you know democrat types they're uh
heavily involved in politics they're
well connected many of them are
high-powered lawyers and the police went
to their homes so people around here are
extremely pissed off what you need to
understand is we are not in a densely
populated area so when someone says you
know my address is one zero zero fake
street the cops are like well in the
span of two miles there's you know five
houses and if we get one number wrong
then it could be the house a few miles
down so they got to send out a ton of
cops
they had to go to a bunch of different
houses that are far away from here and
do wellness checks and all these places
so it wasn't just what we were
experiencing we got the brunt of it we
get all the cops but my understanding is
that the cops actually drove down very
far to other homes and we're knocking on
doors and people are are let's just say
mildly perturbed no kidding at being
disturbed over what would happen and
being asked questions and the cops
saying you know we're getting a report
of a murder-suicide and we need to check
your home i don't know to what extent
they went and checked other houses but i
can say that people are uh my
understanding is that people are angry
and
what i was told is that
i was told we can't tell you how
but we absolutely will find out who did
this
so this is not the area that you want to
be screwing with you know some some
people out here are like extremely
wealthy hot well connected
you know political individuals
and this was it was bigger than just us
you know just this house you know what
bothers me about this one of the things
that bothers me about this is the oxygen
circumstance clause like the fourth
amendment of the constitution you have
the right to protection from
unreasonable search and seizure but
apparently if there's an exigent
circumstance if there's some sort of
emergency
then
it's reasonable to search for the cops
to bust into your house and search you
were you were mentioning that ricketta
law said there was no excellent job this
is this is what i learned from mercado
law last night actually this is the
stuff is coming from his show last night
which i would suggest going and watching
um yeah if they come here and they think
well maybe this is a swatting then they
basically there are no accident
circumstances at that point so if they
said that if there's if there's evidence
that they were on the police scanner
saying we don't we think this might be a
swatting but they came in anyway he said
it's probably a swaddle but they came in
he said we're pretty sure this is a
swamp they're pretty sure it's a
swatting but they came in anyway they
may have overstepped this uh exigent
thing i'm still on their side here i
want to work with these guys and the
local cops and everything but this
oxygen thing is very i mean you want to
talk about totalitarian
abilities to search your house and if
you have a pile of cash on your table
and they take it because of civil asset
forfeiture i don't know if they're
allowed to do that i got an
advertisement on instagram today for gag
coasters that have lines of white powder
on them it was on instagram and it said
gag gifts
and uh
i was just thinking when i'm scrolling
on instagram i'm like what if we had
something like that imagine the the
issue is
there's a reason why i don't want
strangers in my home i don't care if
they're a police officer or not a police
officer i you know when we vet people
when they come here we know who they are
now sometimes cops are criminals not all
cops are good people cops are just
people so i understand they're coming
here because they got a report they want
to they want to help make sure
everyone's okay and everything like that
but once they figured that out when
three people four people actually in the
driveway told them oh yeah everything's
fine and you're wrong and you can't come
in and they said yeah we're pretty sure
sweating now we're gonna come in anyway
i'm like dude that pisses me off a lot
it is so crazy to me that you need to
say something like i really don't want
strangers in my house i feel like you
shouldn't have to say that and i i was
gonna ask i don't know if anybody knows
and i didn't have a chance to look it up
but do we know if swatting is a felony
in the state of maryland i don't know
about this damn pretty sure it's it's
multiple felonies interesting yeah i
think i think it's not only uh like
attempted murder yeah of course uh
it depends on the pro i mean it would be
the d.a interpretation of whether it's
attempted murder i certainly think it is
everyone people have often said it is
but um filing a false police report you
know very serious and multiple times so
that's that's got to be i mean look you
got jesse smallett he got six counts of
felony disorderly conduct for the false
police reports right in this instance
the severity of it sending police
officers and you're putting in you're
putting the cops in fear of death
you're instilling the fear of death in
them i mean these guys were probably
adrenaline going a million miles an hour
you can hear like in the police radio
that people were posting online when
when they're like you know we got this
caller that call you hear the sirens on
one of the guys radio like they're
rushing here yeah so these guys are
probably like here we go man this is
something bad and their heart's going a
million miles an hour they think they
could be walking into a deadly scenario
so i wouldn't say it's attempted murder
on that on their regard but you're
certainly you know putting them in
extreme distress well it's such a waste
of resources too if nothing else if
you're even if you're not like
attempting to murder someone via swat
and saying that i mean treating a swat
visit as attempted murder that's wild to
me like you have to know that they're
overusing force in that i think it's
right i think we need to uh we need to
call it uh exactly as it is
they tried to kill ian oh yep
clearly
yeah
ian was about to run to the bathroom
yeah and if we didn't have
our staff walking outside at that exact
moment
and the cops came in with their guns
ready
going through the house and ian runs
down the hall to go to the bathroom
because what you got to understand is
during the show when we're live
we have we have a bathroom in studio
which is soundproof but ian's not going
to be able to go around to the table so
he's got another door he'd have to run
to the bathroom as quickly as possible
yeah because we're live he runs the show
you don't want to you know just leave
the show for 10 minutes you're going to
run and run out if the cops had walked
up the stairs and it's dark and ian's
running down the hallway of this
building to go to the bathroom and see
him flying through and they're like what
is this thing and they're like some
dudes running at us in this type of way
yeah that's not even funny man i i
almost did like for 10 minutes before
they arrived i was like i got to hit the
bathroom and i was like well this
conversation is good so i stayed and i
was listening for a while and then they
came in i could have been easily out
there running around they were here at 8
20. stop stop they were here at 8 27.
so the the someone so the call was made
at 8 20. the cops arrived at 8 27
that was when andy our cto walks out
into the parking lot and he turns left
he's heading towards our bar and our
outdoor skatepark area and then he stops
and decides i'm gonna go see who's this
person in the driveway and that's when
they realized he it was the police so
this is around 8 29 or so
i think it was only about two or three
minutes later
the backup arrives at that point the
cops would have started getting ready
and moving quickly to come inside maybe
they would have gotten on the on the
megaphone or whatever and y'all i don't
know exactly what their protocol would
have been
but that was i would say around 10
minutes before everything went down
it's very possible that
yeah i'll just say look nothing nothing
bad happened because work
is an office it's a company so people
were doing their jobs and were just like
what's going on but this could have been
way way way worse in some states in some
jurisdictions the protocol literally is
bust down the door with your firearms up
in the air ready to take down any kind
of threat and there have been a lot of
people that died because of swatting
let's just be real and honest with
ourselves this is some people say a
prank but you know this is something
that of course is serious as well and
has led to people dying it's terrorism
yeah because i'll i'll say
there's uh people
the craziest thing to me is the people
who want to uh try and like
look
we had marjorie taylor green on the show
the same day we are getting swatted
she's getting inundated with death
threats it was january 6 right so it
seems obvious that's a day that people
are going to be screaming at her and
coming after her and she came out with
matt gates they issued a statement
and so it was the day after we hosted
her this is when we get a good portion
of the views the next day the podcast
throughout the day gets a ton of traffic
and it was with her
and then at 8 20 20 minutes after the
show starts we get swatted i think it's
terrorism regardless even if it's not
political it's if you send something
some cops to go scare someone that's an
act of terror i mean i don't want to
overuse the word but it's domestic
terrorism they're trying to get cops to
kill you yeah they didn't they they
didn't call the cops and say well
they're trying to get you to kill the
cop it's insane they're trying to get
someone hurt yes
and apparently this individual what they
called uh several different departments
and a suicide hotline two different um
they wanted them to come in here guns
drawn yeah yeah like as fast as they
could yep
terrorism is crazy that's nuts i don't
call for terrorism much but that is a
form of terrorism to do that to someone
you don't call for it much i don't call
for it
i don't like calling the word out
because it's so overused in the last 20
years um this and that can be like
january 6th the people looking at the
wall meemaw that word's been in my head
for like 20 hours
or mamas or whatever me mom looking
around just like the bumbling you know
that they weren't terrorists but they're
getting held for suspected terrorism
like that's i think that's a gross
misjustice there's a lot of a lot of
issues with the oxygen circumstances and
entering the property so what really
pisses me off is that
that someone can lie and the police can
completely disregard four people outside
saying nothing is going on and you're
wrong
when it when it completely contradicts
what they were told on the phone they
were told the phone one guy had harmed
two people and was gonna harm himself
and they encounter four people three
guys and one woman all saying this is a
place of business we're live right now
in studio it's not happening and they
said yep pretty sure now we're going to
come in anyway no
that's that's complete bs i reject that
100 yeah but this is so clearly a form
of intimidation i think that's what
ian's getting out when he talks about
terrorism it doesn't even have to be
political this is so obviously
intimidation and whatever motivated this
it's obviously just to try maybe to get
us to shut up to distract us to get our
minds off some other topic maybe it was
because of a marjorie taylor green
interview but the timing was crazy with
that one but well luke didn't get
distracted or perturbed at all i mean he
was no no he was focused laser focused
exactly
we were just talking on one of the
members podcasts how like you know the
guests will be talking and then it'll go
they'll stop talking and then i'll just
look at luke
oh so anyway anyway
ready to go i don't know how i'm able to
do it but like i'm just able to continue
the train of thought as i'm like looking
at everything that's happening and it's
just kind of continuing the conversation
it's
it's weird but i'm going to start
looking at linda yeah just pitch it to
me
so we we've got a couple different
very uh excellent legal firms
already
filing paperwork like crazy we're going
to be we're going for all the records
the police reports we want to know what
they said before what they said after we
want the 9-1-1 call we want to hear the
person's voice
and then we'll we're gonna you know as
i'm told
they can't tell me how but they're going
to find out who did this that's kind of
scary i know
well
listen listen look let's get serious for
a second we had a sitting member of
congress on this show and the next day
someone swatted us which is fbi's on it
i mean i i'd have to imagine it's i'd
say so yeah and as the person made the
phone call from out of the jurisdiction
if it includes we're
we're uh uh literally 30 seconds from
the state border yeah so this could be
that this could be a federal issue
already this is definitely a demon area
yeah yeah i was just like
we're not going to tell you how but
interesting we will find out i'm lying
i'm like oh man thanks empire
i'll
as bad as everything is i'm not i'm not
completely i don't believe not
necessarily believe it's true i
certainly believe there's powerful
interests look their attitude is we can
fight with each other
but don't you screw with us you like
look at what happened on january 6th all
of these members of congress are like we
don't care if you're out in the streets
hitting each other but when you come to
our house oh oh it's so they so i i
don't know maybe maybe they don't like
mtg but i'd also imagine they might be
saying like we may not like her but the
last thing i want is to go on a show to
promote my campaign and have this happen
so they're going to be like find this
person yeah shut it down that's
interesting yeah i wonder if they'll use
her to try to kind of send a message i'd
be fascinated to see what happens and
i'm curious if the fbi is on it and i do
want to know what these law firms have
to say about the exigent thing i want to
know if there's like a case there to be
made because well i mean i don't know
we're going to do i mean i know but
nothing happened they left so there's
like there's no standing for anything
like what really what are our damages
but like that that's all my home i think
we gotta remodel the whole thing how
dare they just like
you can a government can redefine what a
word means and if they want to redefine
exigent to mean like any
thought that maybe someone's sneezing
inside their house
they're actually pretty specific there's
like three agent circumstances they're
very specific and the one that we fell
under was uh imminent harm was was about
to occur but they clearly didn't believe
that was the case right which is why to
be determined it's going to be other
ones are like red pursuit hot pursuit
laws like if you if you think the guy's
going to get away like if they're in a
car that's like considered a hot pursuit
thing so because they might be gone in a
second if you don't act i think we're
we're headed down to really i think 2022
i i mean i'm saying this a couple week
or two ago i'm like you guys i hope
you're ready for how insane it's gonna
be you don't get it look
my my segment i did at 4 pm was about
how
they're trying to disqualify donald
trump so he can't run for office they've
been trying to disqualify him and
they're also mark elias a democrat
lawyer says that he believes mid this
year you're going to see
disqualifications of republicans running
for office they know they can't win
against the trump populists the america
first nationalists so what they're going
to do is they're going to use january 6
to claim
section 3 of the 14th amendment was
violated and then make it so that
marjorie taylor green donald trump and
other populist republicans
will not have their names appear on the
ballots and will be ineligible to hold
office this is the direction things are
going that is insane
we're going to see smear campaigns
the harassment is going to be intense
this is it's january 7th day and we're
here talking about the aftermath of us
getting swatted seriously 2022 is going
to be nuts 20 2018 was the democrats
being like okay we're gonna we're gonna
take back the house and they did and we
all complained and we're like wow i
guess we didn't see that coming then
2019 you get the presidential primaries
2020 was in was really nuts
2020 was insane the writhing the 100-day
sieges on cities it was probably the
craziest year of my life yes it was
easily yeah yeah and then 2021
everyone's kind of burned out there's no
big elections
now we're getting into 2022 which is
republicans have a real chance to take
back the house and the senate and
displace the establishment's authority
because trump controls the republican
party you got people like ted cruz that
would love to pull it back to
establishment they can't do it as much
as they try and pretend they're not
this is where they're going to pull out
all the stops
if you if you think that the shadow
campaign to fortify the election was bad
take a look at them overtly tweeting we
will straight up just say
your politician can't be in office they
will literally just decree that
so this is that's beyond elections
this is this is
civil war but this is a sign of panic on
there and i mean this is a tell right so
is this a good thing or a bad thing
yeah it's a good point actually it's a
good question it it it may be
that they're so they're so desperate
they know they're going to lose that the
only thing they have left in their
arsenal is overt cheating
and what i mean by that is using law
fair political lawfare to disqualify
your opponent instead of actually
running against them right that may be
that may be a positive a good good news
that that if people go out and vote in
the primaries and uh uh primary these
neocon and established republicans get
in some america first populists who are
just there for the working class want to
bring factories back and secure our
borders they'll probably win
and that
i think is why they're going so hard
against anybody who opposes the machine
because the traditional methods aren't
working for them anymore people are
breaking through the lies the narrative
isn't working well there's a lot of
things that play here specifically with
covid and especially what happened in
south africa with many medical
professionals saying that this is going
to happen here in the united states and
that soon we might be experiencing the
end of this pandemic and historically
speaking newsweek actually talked about
this yesterday they talked about how at
the end of pandemics throughout human
history usually this leads to a lot of
civil unrest so i think this is also a
big possibility
it routinely does happen it historically
does happen but also financially there's
a lot of things happening that people
are still not aware of usually economic
trends take a long time to kind of
surface and really affect people they're
not
imminent they usually take months
to fully affect individuals so i think
we're going to be feeling the full
ramification of hyper money printing so
there's a lot of things at play here
that create a lot of instability and
with all of this instability i think
it's very fair to say that we're in for
a rough ride not just politically not
just with this larger divide and conquer
agenda the left versus the right but
there's a lot of other circumstances i
would say accident accident
exigent circumstances that are leading
to of course the probability of some
major troubles ahead i'm gonna get luke
a dictionary for his birthday yeah yes
and then like whatever he has the word
will like we'll pull it up and be like
no he can write his own dictionary
actually that's that's because i could
make my own
that's actually a really good idea no no
for real though to make like a t-shirt
with all of the words yeah like luke's
words exacerbate oh that would be
awesome like one of those like where you
got to circle the word in the big maze
of letters
or like what's the puzzle thing where
you have to circle like a word
search
word search how did you guys know what a
word search is they didn't know the word
for words dude i think in different ways
than your average man hey i've been i've
been looking at um the crypto market it
is getting smeared what you were saying
was making me think about it and i don't
know how related it is but it looks like
there's a coordinated move to smear the
market
uh drive the prices no no no no no huge
buy-up
so the the civil unrest in kazakhstan
shut down a major uh mining operation
interesting so this caused huge price
fluctuations and things like that and
they might be using that as an excuse to
drive the market down well no i think
people are gonna exploit it seeing it
coming but i think this is just all that
you know kazakhstan crypto what's
happening um i mean us getting swatted
what's happening with um
trying to disqualify trump yo the global
system whatever it is is falling apart
so it's funny that you get someone like
alex jones he mentions the globalists
and they're planning all that stuff and
i'm kind of i'm like looking around the
world and i'm like maybe that plan ain't
working you know whatever what i i don't
agree with alex on a good majority of
what he believes about the globalists
but it is a fact that there are global
elites that work that coordinate
obviously they do trade negotiations and
deals and everything and they have an
idea of how the system is supposed to be
working but it's not well no no no but
this is what i kind of want to add here
because this is order out of chaos they
create the chaos and out of the chaos
out of the panic out of the suffering
out of the fighting they create a new
system that people naturally go to
because they already have it in play and
it's going to be their solution to the
problems that they caused that's how i
personally see it that's for that's my
opinion especially understanding how
they previously worked before especially
seeing their writings especially seeing
just just how brazen they are with it
especially with the world economic forum
and the documents that they release
bragging about what they want to do and
if you think of a way of how are you
going to usurp people's sovereignty how
are you going to take away their
financial mobility how are you going to
subjugate them in almost every aspect of
their existence well you make their
existence right now unbearable so they
come into your system begging to be
under of course your new world order
that they're conveniently building that
works in their favor even more so that's
how i see it from from my perspective
you know what's really crazy is this
conspiracy theory that donald trump
wasn't supposed to win
and because he did it forced the
establishment to speed up their timeline
yes so basically this is the conspiracy
i'm not saying it's true okay i'm just
saying this is you know the conspiracy
chatter that hillary was supposed to win
in 2016 and they were supposed to slowly
be pushing out a lot of these draconian
policies over four years instead trump
wins they panic and don't know how to
stop him because trump was changing
things back in favor of america which
was rewinding the clock on the
establishment plan
so then finally in the last year they
had to do everything they wanted to do
in a span in four years but in in like
six seven months
so everything got crammed and everybody
could see it happening because you can
only move people so far so fast so that
then the idea is that
now they're trying to get back on track
with it but too many people were shocked
by this disruption in the system
if hillary had won
and then they started doing like look in
2018 is when they changed the definition
of anti-vaxxer to someone who opposes
government mandates
again i'm not saying this is true i'm
saying these are what people are are
asserting as to why they believe the
establishment had a plan for draconian
lockdowns they very clearly wanted to
sign the trans-pacific partnership and
get cheap oil out of malaysia in
australia if you give aid and comfort to
people who don't like the mandates
you're deemed an anti-vaxxer according
to the government officials in australia
that have decreed it that's an absolute
lunacy they're changing definitions by
the day they're confusing people as much
as they can and they're trying to create
a panic they're trying to create a fight
they're trying to create something that
of course will make us not realize
what's really happening to the general
public because that's the only way they
could get away with their bigger power
grabs that their uh conducting right now
yeah the um the trans-pacific
partnership had a clause called the
investor state dispute settlement clause
that gave corporations like malaysian
corporations the power to sue the
american government if the american
people were discriminating in quotes
against them by not buying their oil so
if we chose out of exxon's malaysian oil
production they're going to sue us
they're going to sue the the citizens
and trump buried that he said no i'm not
signing it trash it but hillary was
about to sign it um and that's obama
wanted to set back a lot of the plans
for it's not about this this illuminati
it's not about the cabal it's about one
guy who works for an oil company who's
sitting there going they're going to do
this tpp thing this is great news for us
tell the investors then trump gets in
and they're like god
you know what man he just screwed us
over yeah and then what happens is you
don't
you don't need grand conspiracies for
these things to happen you need a small
handful of ultra wealthy elites birds of
a feather flocked together they're not
colluding or coordinating in some grand
conspiracy they have similar interests
because they're leaders of industry and
free trade agreements benefit their
companies we can send more factories
overseas when trump did that he pissed
them off at the same time all of a
sudden they're donating money to super
pacs against trump it looks coordinated
but is it it's actually called a
standalone complex now conspiracies
exist too don't get me wrong i mean
there could be a guy to oil company and
he calls up his other buddhist oil
company and he's like hey we're getting
screwed over here you know let's lobby
against this right so things like that
could absolutely happen but you gotta
you gotta admit when trump got in
smashing the tpp that was like kicking
the balls of all these big international
corporations well some people are
arguing that obama wasn't going to sign
it anyway that's the art counter
argument to of course that claim i see
it a little bit differently but i
understand exactly where you're coming
from because
and we don't even have to argue about
this because whether your case is true
or my case is true whether it's it's
people looking out for their interests
or people colluding together and working
together it doesn't matter the important
fact to all agree on here is that
they're doing it and because they're
doing it this is screwing the average
american over it's giving them
less freedom it's giving them less
economic opportunities it's giving them
less prosperity and sovereignty and
that's a serious issue that is getting
completely out of hand especially in our
current way of life that is being
threatened by a lot of these globalists
that are taking advantage of this
tragedy for their own personal benefits
so i don't even want to argue i see a
little bit differently but they're doing
it and we need to realize that before
it's too late the end result
can't go into a building without your
app
you've got to scan it it tracks every
place you go you use it for everything
it's going to be for your you know
buying stuff i've already i've already
got on my phone the the near field
communications you know wallet you just
tap your phone to the thing that's crazy
then they're gonna now they're doing the
vax passports everywhere cook county the
second largest county in the united
states has a vaccine mandate this is not
one city this is like dozens of cities a
big city like chicago and then all of
these smaller suburbs are all under this
mandate a few of these suburbs have said
screw you we will not enforce this and
some of them are just ignoring it out
right but this is i couldn't believe it
when i heard that cook county this is
this is the county that surrounds
chicago in the chicagoland area that's
crazy to me so your future is going to
be you don't got your phone on you or
your battery died you can't come in
sorry
you're not being tracked in your in your
with your tracking device sorry you
haven't given us all of your data so we
know where where and when you poop too
bad that's nice sounds discriminatory
against people that don't have
electricity
yeah yeah
yeah they'll they'll then then you'll
get the left argument they'll be like
the left will come out and say obama
phones yeah no they'll say they'll say
it's not it's not discriminatory it's
just that we have to give everyone free
phones that's what they'll end up saying
let's preload some software on there and
traffic yep so this is inevitable
there's no way really to avoid it at
this point
no no no no i mean you know you brought
it up earlier i think they're desperate
uh look i don't know if there was a
grand plan for any of this like that i
was just saying like people believe
there's a grand plan for this it's it's
certainly true that they they are
working towards this now but i think
it's less this like overarching
conspiracy among a global elite group
like alex jones might say and more so
some democrats went to china saw how
their totalitarian communist party
system works and want that for
themselves it's clearly not a an
all-encompassing conspiracy because you
have people like ron desantis you have
people like donald trump people like
donald trump clearly disagrees with a
lot of his own supporters they even boo
him sometimes but he's certainly not in
line with other establishment elites
i think you have a lot of wealthy
individuals that lean democratic that
want a communist chinese communist party
style system in here and they're working
towards it and then you have other
billionaires you have the koch brothers
that
not necessarily involved in that but
maybe a little bit in some ways then you
have the mercers who oppose it so it's
not like all the ultra elites are all in
line together it's just very powerful
people with aligned interests will align
their interests not through a conspiracy
necessarily but just by doing similar
things and there's very few
[Music]
know how else you could see it but not
you know criminal to be honest from my
perspective no i i hear you're saying
that
i'll put it this way
the the typically the idea that makes
people believe it's impossible is like
there's ten cabal members they have a
secret meeting where they come to the
table and they say how can we control
the world and they're like
and they write down in their secret book
and they turn up my shadow typically
when and then there's like occult
ceremonies and mock child sacrifices and
a whole bunch of other stuff sorry go on
no but my point is often these meetings
would seem
banal right you'd see a guy in a suit
walk up to another guy and be like i
haven't seen you in a few months so look
we're gonna be doing a big export from
california to china but we need this tpp
man and they're gonna be like don't
worry we'll take care of it for you
we're going to put a bunch of money into
this super pac and so if if a regular
person saw the meeting they'd be like
what's wrong with that it's just a
business meeting among you know people
running companies but when they have
look i'll tell you i'll put it this way
if i were to tell you that a large group
of ultra wealthy billionaire elites and
princes and kings and politicians were
meeting to discuss how they were going
to control oil around the world would
you call that a conspiracy in fact they
have these meetings all the time they
are just like oil gas expo in libya and
then all of the big companies show up
and they walk in and get their name
badge and they walk around shaking hands
oh jim yeah with exxon nice to meet you
and they signed up the forums like well
if a regular person saw these things
they would not think it's a conspiracy
when i was in when i was in brazil i
went to a weapons expo there were
generals there were you know high
ranking military officials pilots there
were politicians i watched one guy
walking with a bunch of bodyguards like
you know in suits and they're armed
it's not a conspiracy
it's a convention but all of these
government
elites are there colluding on the best
weapons for suppressing dissent now if i
told you princes kings world leaders and
billionaires were meeting to discuss the
production of weapons to suppress
dissent around the world people would be
like that's a crazy conspiracy it was a
convention it was called the latin
american aerospace defense convention or
something like i went there and walked
around and i saw all of these people
there having meetings having lunch
cracking open champagne that's that's
the conspiracy that's happening in plain
sight but regular people when they hear
this they think it's impossible because
they imagine it like a creepy cabal
underground going muahaha instead of
business well to be fair there is an
aspect of it and for the average person
hearing it they're kind of like wait
what's going on here and for some people
it scares them away for some people it's
like okay wait wait wait let's really
look into this and it kind of awakens
them so there's different strategies out
there but when you look into stuff like
the bohemian grove and and spirit
cooking and literally very powerful
people taking blood and writing messages
on the walls with human excrement and
and other feces and other horrible
things to talk with interdimensional
species that's a bunch of weird stuff
that has been documented has has been
happening going along with a lot of
powerful people so there is an element
of that but it loses some people and
some people are like wait that's too
crazy i can't believe that and it
shatters their world view and
automatically they kind of shut off and
they put up their blinders some people
though are like wait probably with the
way my life's been going with the with
the way i've been screwed over with
taxes with the way i've been screwed
over by my boss and have having this
horrible office job and been grinding
through this entire machine probably but
so there's two perspectives um and i
think both are relevant i think when it
comes to discussing powerful interests
global elites
bankers military and stuff when you get
into the weird occult stuff that a lot
of them do that's when you'll lose
regular people
because i i don't think it's look if you
come to me and you're like did you know
that these you know powerful elites meet
in a place called bohemian grove or
whatever i'd be like bro i have no idea
what that has to do with my life and why
i can't get a good job that pays me well
but if you go and say did you know the
government printed something like 40 of
all u.s dollars in the past year which
has devalued your purchasing power i'll
put it this way because of what the fed
has done and what the gut what the
politicians have done
all the money in your bank account was
cut in half huh and people are going to
be like what why how what that speaks to
people and then you can start getting
into here's why they do it here's what
they've been doing and here's a book
about a place called jekyll island and
then sometimes people like gillane come
across that are so reprehensible that
people care about their weirdness
how amazing that they were like we're
going to charge her with trafficking can
victor have trafficking to no one that's
it she was she was convicted of
trafficking children
to no one yeah she was running an
illegal business with a lot of customers
the customers who participated in this
legal business who paid for her to be a
part of this illegal business who made
this illegal business possible no no
look look
that must be wrong if if there were
people who were engaged in this business
with her and paying her to do it
certainly they would have been
criminally charged and prosecuted right
and considering they haven't been she
must have just been standing there
offering up trafficking people and then
they arrested her for it there certainly
must have been no real customers to what
her and epstein were doing yeah no
powerful clients at all
makes a good point when you want to talk
to people about really how crazy things
get eventually you will get a story like
epstein where it's it's true we know
it's true the evidence is out and they
even convicted uggy lane she's guilty
and now people are like what about the
rest of them all the people who are
flying on that plane and going there and
then you can be like conspiracies do
happen and here's one so i'll tell you
this if i'm not a big fan of most
conspiracies because a lot of people
connect dots that shouldn't be connected
that's the problem however if there's
ever something you truly believe and
someone's a skeptic you can just be like
i may be wrong
but epstein
will go
that's a good point like maybe i should
you know consider i don't know
everything the klaus schwab thing is
kind of i don't even know if there's
does he even land in a conspiracy world
right now he's absolutely blatantly said
he wants to create a corporate
government collusive yeah that's a form
of global governance he's worth point
nine five million dollar klaus schwab
his net worth is under a million dollars
he's the head of the economic forum
leading the global change in global
economics and he's supposedly worth less
than a million dollars according to the
ceo
ian there's a lot of money laundering
and the people who have a lot of money
are not on the forbes top money list
right they hide it in assets they hide
it in stocks they hide it in commodities
they're able to of course transfer their
wealth in ways that of course are not
seen jeffrey epstein for uh for example
here he was working with major banking
institutions whether it was brown
brothers and harriman or chase bank jp
morgan and chase they were able to of
course break the laws break regulations
didn't follow standard protocols and
gave him a special
kind of treatment that no one else gets
that allowed him to launder his money
that allowed him to
facilitate his international trafficking
operation of small children and these
financial institutions were absolutely
complicit they're major banking
institutions and if they're doing that
for epstein what do you think they're
doing for a cloud schwab you think
they're not hiding his assets or his
money powerful people always hide their
money and they of course keep it away
from everyone else and and that's why
there's a saying that only stupid people
pay taxes i heard uh vladimir putin's
uh worth 700 billion
wow wow yeah well i don't know i heard
he has a lot of property all over the
world and a lot of international bank
accounts that can't be tracked back to
him and a lot of other individuals
around him that also have you know or
his kind of proxies or or financial
sherpas as some people call them so
i mean putin's one of them but but you
got to understand i mean he's one person
this is the entire system that's being
run this way with so many people just
hiding their money avoiding taxes not
paying any of it expecting you to give
30 percent of everything you earn
uh which is this article no one knows
putin's exact net worth but many
speculate he's the wealthiest person on
the planet his one billion dollar palace
and 500 million dollar yacht explain why
wow so i can't remember where i saw this
an article here we go uh bill browder
estimates putin had accumulated 200
billion dollars of ill-gotten gains in
2018.
with the global lockdowns and seeing all
the billionaires skyrocket and in their
in their net worth
putin's probably way way up there
wealthiest guy in the planet yeah
epstein is really interesting because i
feel like he kind of puts this kind of
corruption in the spotlight and that is
one of the reasons that i'm glad lou
hammers is home but i was going to say
to circle back what tim was talking
about earlier when we talk about
conspiracy we do generally tend to think
of the bohemian grove crazy people
sacrificing whatever on whatever altar
um but it's somewhere between the
mundane just doing business handshake
with a smile at some
boringly named convention and epstein
epstein is like oh my gosh there's
something serious here well he plays
into all of this because when you're
dealing with so much power when you're
dealing with so much money you need dirt
on other individuals in order to have
them in your pocket to make sure that
they don't break the game that you're
playing against everyone else so when
you're doing horrible things you have
that blackmail saying um you're not
going to fight this you're going to go
along with this because we're going to
expose you and destroy your entire lives
and careers that's why epstein is so
important here but also bohemian growth
mock child sacrifices male prostitutes
shipped in according to the new york
post so there's there's a lot of things
that they have on a lot of these
powerful individuals and a lot of weird
people go there conan o'brien
goes to the bohemian grove and so do a
lot of celebrities so do a lot of people
in hollywood so do of course a lot of
very very prominent people in our
society would you go if you got invited
probably not still honest yeah um well i
feel like i really feel like dirt like
epstein had on people is more valuable
than any kind of money oh this that kind
of control this actually stokes one of
my questions you guys hear the panama
papers oh yeah it's kind of revealed
like five years ago april 3rd 2016 214
offshore entities uh financial and
attorney information was released and
these date back to the 70s 21 214 000
offshore entities financial and these
are people that are like this all
tax-free are these all people that are
ducking taxes basically luke do you know
what were you saying exactly the panama
papers these
that seems like an intelligence agency
kind of operation because it directly
hits a lot of international elites uh
instead of domestic uh politicians in
the united states i might stand
corrected on that but from
you know this happened a couple of years
ago
but from my basic kind of refreshed
memory just going off the top of my head
i do believe that there were some kind
of intelligence agencies tied to of
course making this a political hack and
release yeah rather than uh than a real
financial there's also a lot of
journalists i think that were tied to
this that were also killed uh and taken
out the original the original reporter
right the original reporter so at least
the story i think was killed i want to
be accurate here so we'd have to look up
this story to to again and it's got it
and it's a few years old so i don't
think we can do it just sitting here and
trying doing justice i remember reading
that putin's buddy who's like this art
collector had a they found a
account with him there and looked like a
bunch of money had been funneled to his
friend
and was putin involved i don't know
maybe mysterious i mean the thing is
when you've got stories like the panama
papers and epstein people really need to
sit back when they hear the word
conspiracy and be like all right all
right show me your evidence and i'll at
least give it a google search what
always bothered me about journalists in
new york especially when i worked there
is that they'd hear a story and i'd be
like
they would hear a conspiracy theory and
just laugh at it i'd be like did you
even bother google searching it because
some of these things like the gulf of
tonkin is the perfect example we didn't
we didn't we didn't learn about that
being a conspiracy or potent
i i think it's
most likely until uh what like the the
2010s
you know you know when we think
absolutely
90s uh to to be honest with you i think
earlier than no no because i remember uh
uh from for those that aren't familiar
the gulf of tonkin incident was what got
us involved in vietnam and it was like
we got attacked and we had to enter and
then i remember even when i was younger
they were like no we got attacked and it
wasn't until like the 2000s they were
like oh actually we staged that that's
when it became really prominent like the
in the mid 2000s when like with the
internet videos back when you know
youtube was kind of a wild west it looks
like 1981 is when they started to
consider the ambush unfounded
really really apparent ambush yeah i go
deeper on this captain herrick uh
journalist robert shearer
examined the logs to determine that the
first torpedo
the ambush was in fact no no it's 2003.
um robert uh mcnamara admitted the
attack on the systematics happened on
the second but the august fourth goal of
tonkan attack which was
for which washington authorized
retaliation never happened so that's
that's you gotta understand like the u.s
lied to enter a war i wonder when
they're gonna come clean about kennedy
if they ever never generations if if
ever at all that one's a lot more
difficult i know like the goal like
here's what i can say oh i got an idea
when we when we have wikipedia telling
us that the gulf of tonkin incident in
2003 was revealed isn't that crazy well
then i can definitively be like okay
well what do you want me to say to that
right the kennedy stuff is kind of like
no one's come out yet i don't right
right there's like a deathbed confession
it looks like that um oswald was
involved with some people that were
doing some nefarious stuff and he my
guess is that he let them borrow his gun
because the way they pinned it on oswald
was they found his gun in the building
and then they were like hey then they
went and oswald was in the building
where he worked and they were like
you're the guy let's go then two days
later
have you ever
you see how o.j simpson wrote that book
if i did it yeah and it was basically
like i guess people say it was a
confession or whatever and then the
family of you know one of the victims
took the if and made it really small and
so it says i did it
you ever see that movie shooter
with mark wahlberg no i don't know no
have you seen it is that the journalist
no no no it's uh so mark wahlberg is uh
one of the world's best snipers
and then he gets these government these
government guys are like we need your
help because someone's gonna try to
assassinate this politician
and he's like i'm off the grid i don't
want to be involved and they're like you
know just come with us you'll get paid
really well and so he goes they have him
in this building and they're like okay
where do you think the snipe you know
the bad guy might be and he's like it's
got to be over there then all of a
sudden the politician gets hit
and then some bumbling dumb cop walks in
the room and they're like all right
shoots mark wahlberg who falls out the
window and the point was they were
trying to frame mark wahlberg with the
assassination attempt and so the movie
is
trying to lee harvey oswald him yeah
yeah
you guys i'm a patsy if you hear him
tell everyone he's a patsy it sounds so
honest he's like didn't oswald didn't
oswald say he didn't do it yeah he was
telling the reporters i'm a pack
they're doing this to me and then they
jack ruby who i think the fbi had dirt
on jack ruby so they had him go
and ruby and they and they silenced them
and got rid of that story and then they
made ruby look like a hero and the the
cia still keeps documents around that so
awesome i'm so glad that um i i think
it's important to note
whatever really all went down yeah it's
overstuffed i don't i don't trust
official narratives a lot of this stuff
but whatever really went down is
probably very different from what we
think because we're we're getting
tidbits and we're looking through a
keyhole trying to understand this stuff
but i'll just say this as for every
every official government story you know
you take it with a grain of salt the
best you can do is like okay that's the
general that's the official narrative
and understanding but you got you got to
realize this whether for nefarious
purposes or for you know genuinely good
reasons secrets get kept
you know if if the u.s went out and said
here's like a list of all of the
technology we have we we'd take we'd be
conquered in two seconds we can't give
away our tactical secrets and our you
know oliver stone actually said that
lyndon johnson after kennedy died was
like thought maybe it was a russian or a
cuban assassination attempt so didn't
want to make it like a global
ordeal out of it and create world war
three so that was why they kind of
hushed up the why lyndon johnson may
have hushed it up not that he was
involved this is that's 130 but uh his
uh film about it jfk by oliver stone
absolutely incredible film definitely
worth the watch and it's very
thought-provoking it's a huge red pill
just watching i revisited about a month
or so ago and man oh man that movie has
aged beautifully in fact uh oliver stone
just did a new documentary called
revisiting jfk it just dropped on
showtime where he revisits the whole
thing let me let's let's do this
let's talk about how to control your
mind
i got here a clip from joe rogan oh yeah
joe posted so uh there's two videos
playing side by side top top and bottom
on the top is cnn's version broadcast
version of joe rogan's announcement that
he was being treated for covet on the
bottom is joe's actual video for those
that can't see this is insane
cnn altered the colors to make joe rogan
look grayish green sick it's crazy let
me i'm gonna play a little bit
okay okay i guess you can't hear it oh
here we go
z pack
it's hard to describe this for people
who are listening other than
they altered the colors of joe rogan's
skin to make him look like he's dying
yeah they make him look like a
frankenstein green potato
like literally
green potato joe just just posted the
clip and he put yellow journalism fake
news
here's what you guys need to understand
about this someone at cnn
and probably more than one person
probably someone with some authority
said we are going to edit this footage
make joe look very sick
we're they're not going to gain any
extra views by making joe look sick
no people aren't going to be like hey
everybody watch this video of joe rogan
no no no
what they're doing is the people who
watch cnn will just see a very sickly
looking joe rogan
all they're really doing it's not about
ratings this is cnn in my opinion
deliberately trying to manipulate the
narrative to mind control to brainwash
to propagandize absolutely i mean this
is the same time they were making the
arguments that joe rogan was taking
horse medicine and of course was dealing
with covid in a way which they clearly
presented him not dealing with in a good
way meanwhile in the video he's like hey
you know i just got covered a couple
days ago i'm feeling better than ever i
took this and this and this and this i
threw the kitchen sink at it so so their
narrative was very important to upkeep
one of the ways that they kept this
narrative is by faking this video by by
lying to
the american people to portray it as if
he wasn't doing well which is absolutely
ridiculous you need you need to go to
joe rogan's instagram if you can't see
this because you're listening on the
podcast you need to see this because
your jaw will hit the floor
they make him look like he's got like uh
lupus or or liver cancer super like pale
white light and dark shadow yeah this is
why cnn is the enemy of humanity i mean
this is it and and this was their
reaction to it along with other
corporate media representatives that
were mad that he got better he was able
to improve his health and so was dana
wright so was aaron rodgers and so were
a lot of people including congressman
and women that take the same treatment
as he does the treatment that they're
trying to of course say doesn't exist
doesn't work and it's and it's based on
horses that's ridiculous and criminal
regardless of that if you go to your
doctor and your doctor says they have a
pr they have a recommendation a
prescription why is cnn telling people
not to do that yeah why it's it's
sponsored by
pfizer exactly is that why i've
i've i've seen people who have had liver
failure
and what so so uh lupus makes you turn
yellow right uh no so lupus is not the
one that makes jungles it's jaundice and
yeah that is caused by liver failure yes
yeah so they uh they make them look like
what's the what's the what's the skin
cancer like what what's what's the
cancer that makes you turn green you
know what i'm talking about no gangrene
no no there's a there's a cancer that
affects an organ that makes your skin
start pigmenting green
like they it looks like he is dying
they cnn made this they want people to
see this and be like wow yeah
getting out of head on the story they're
like oh we got to get ahead on this one
let's make it look bad they did it to
trump they made it orange remember that
photo where they made his face super
bright orange and it was just his hair
was blowing back yeah yeah let me see if
i can pull that one up what were you
going to say i was going to say this
actually looks to me like they're trying
to make it look like he has too much
silver in his system because silver
actually makes people turn blue but i
was going to say i did see a tweet
earlier today from a lady who said oh my
gosh look at joe rogan he looks so gray
and sick i can't believe that he was
actually saying that he's healthy and
i'm like it worked on at least one
person
oh my gosh yeah they totally altered
this picture
i researched that blue silver skin guy
it turned out he was rubbing silver on
his
face was making at his house so it
wasn't being done properly apparently no
so there was a family somewhere in the
deep south that was taking too much
colloidal silver and it starts to show
in your skin because your body can't
excrete it because it's metal
did you see the guy who's fully blue he
looks like a smurf i haven't seen him
but i did see a picture of like the
whole family so there's like a whole
bunch of them who are obviously doing
something you got to look up the blue
skinned silver guy it's pure blue it's
like dark dark dark and he's been
rubbing it on himself which is why
that'll do it but he didn't tell people
that at first so he caused a panic about
wow
freaking out small doses of colloidal
silver which have antimicrobial
properties yeah maybe maybe just a
little yeah
that's why they made silverware is
because the it would be really good for
your immune system to put it in your
mouth huh interesting about all that
that's my job
we do i do have the image where is that
trump and even snopes is like this
twitter account white house photos is
not connected to what do they say uh
twitter is not connected with or
controlled by the white house itself its
actions do not represent or reflect
white house interests or policies
and they had this like look trump does
have a spray tan it's true sure yeah but
they would they would you'd see them on
tv on cnn and um and it's just like they
saturate his face to make it look bright
orange
and then when you see him you're like
when you see him and act in real life
you're like oh yeah he does have a spray
tan but it's not that crazy
that's it's it's
in the movie don't look up
they show the right as being the people
chanting don't look up
the right-wing politicians are like
don't don't look up those aren't
familiar it's about a comet that's going
to hit the earth and kill everybody and
so the republicans and the right-wing
are like ain't no comet i'm not going to
look up because if you look up you see
it right and i'm like yo that's brian
stelter not the right the right is going
debate me
why won't aoc debate me that's what the
wright is doing the right is demanding
you come and discuss these ideas
it's cnn that's saying don't look at the
news anywhere else
yeah absolutely it's it's
just when you think you can't get any
more absurd we have this and and this is
an old story joe rogan of course
just posted this on his instagram just a
couple moments ago but this happened a
long time ago so um we have to
understand that this is what the
corporate media does they they lie
they're professional liars i think they
there's a lot of sociopaths within them
that obviously do the bidding of the
special interests and whether it was the
banker bailouts whether it was the
weapons of mass destruction in iraq we
have to understand especially if you're
a youtube moderator you should really
consider the harm the real life
consequences and harm that the corporate
media has caused so many innocent
countless numbers of individuals that
had their life ruined and destroyed and
ended because of the corporate media
lies and then to destroy something that
potentially could help people destroy
this
alternative that members of congress are
being treated with that right there is
some next level criminality that needs
to be addressed right away because when
you have someone trying to knowingly lie
in a way that will hurt you
you have criminal actions being
conducted on you by criminal
institutions who will do and say
anything for a buck i just want to add
they're desperate man yes let this be
the takeaway because joe rogan has the
biggest show
in culture culture and politics the
biggest joe he gets more than 10 times
he gets like 12 or 13 times the traffic
on one of his shows that they get in
prime time and they think they're going
to get away with smearing him in this
way joe puts out one instagram post and
it everybody everybody sees it yes and
it
it's just flushing cnn is flushing
themselves down the toilet by doing this
chris you worked in a lot of media
institutions like
how would this go over if someone would
come to you being like hey we're going
to do this like what would happen
how how could this happen you worked in
a lot of newsrooms i think your
perspective is valid here well
thankfully i haven't been in any kind of
corporate press institutions you know so
i can only imagine how it would go over
there um this would certainly not fly uh
in any place that i've worked for many
reasons but i do
something i am thinking about right now
is the kind of could you imagine being
the person at cnn that is making that
call i mean can you imagine like the
sort of god-like thrill that you have
with even if you're not shaping the
narrative because obviously they're
failing they're flushing themselves down
the toilet like you said but at least
they perceive themselves to have this
god-like power of manipulating and
sculpting exactly what they think their
viewers are going to live and and
experience i mean that has to give them
some sort of uh is there some sort of a
sick thrill that gets them excited
yeah but it's intoxicating right it has
to be yeah yeah it was a it was like a
drug when i worked at mines for like
five years i was doing this kind of
thing deciding what was gonna get seen
and it was like i had to fight the
addictive force of it because it's like
such a powerful you're like i'm gonna
decide what a million people see now i'm
gonna decide what and one cheap employee
gets to do that in a moment and then
like every employee gets to take a turn
and decide and the power is so
unnecessary remember how they kept using
that same footage of italy during the
cove pandemic
they kept taking the same clip from
italian hospital and it was being aired
all over the u.s just absolutely crazy
where would we be without the internet
if we couldn't share this news rapidly
in afghanistan still
for sure yeah definitely probably syria
and libya and no joke maybe even
literally like some of us would be aware
because yeah we wouldn't be able to
counter that narrative people might have
signed up believing the lies
so there is a quote that says insults
are the last resort of insecure people
with a crumbling position trying to
appear confident and i do believe that
is the case so that makes me wonder what
exactly it means when some gigantic
media conglomerate like cnn is turning
people different colors how badly have
you lost when you literally have to
fine-tune the color of someone's
recording to make them look sick and bad
and uncomfortable like
trump joe needs to like take that money
he's got and
hire more of him yes like hire many more
joe rogans and make more podcasts and
i don't know how he does it but
and legally go after cnn i mean what are
you doing what are you waiting for i
mean they're they're they're besmirching
you they're lying about you they're
slandering you they're saying you're on
horse medicine knowingly when when they
know they're not you had one of their
co-hosts on and and you confronted him
and he admitted you were right and then
he went back on cnn and said oh no he
was wrong are you kidding me like the
slap
in the face sorry i'm hitting
microphones here it's gonna get crazy
it's gonna get wild here get ready
you're gonna get rugged yeah don't do it
but but the fact that they're
they can't get away with this if people
hold them accountable you could hold
them accountable in a court of law i
think it's more than enough time to do
it but this is also why internet
censorship is so important of an issue
because when we see people censor time
and time again it's not cnn that gets
hit for doing these incredulous horrible
actions it's not the real life harm that
they cause that they get held
responsible for no it's a small
independent media organization talking
to their friends it's medical doctors
talking about their findings it's people
expressing their opinions that are
getting hit and destroyed and having
their livelihoods taken away by big tech
censorship as of course they're
promoting cnn they're they're ranking
them in the algorithm even higher so
everyone sees them on the front page
it's sick and disgusting and and i'm
also learning right now that matt walsh
was just suspended on twitter whoa
over tweets uh relating to gender so
mike cernovich is tweeting about this uh
right now so so again his voice gets
taken out here and again i disagree with
matt on some issues i agree with him on
some issues but but you know again he's
coming from a different perspective why
is he being targeted why is cnn still
the preferred platform for big tech
social media that gets to spew their
lives to the general public that's crazy
do we have the story yet
i'm trying to pull it up twitter's
annoying i was looking up the companies
at alphabet google's parent company owns
the other day and they have a lot more
companies than they did three years ago
they have like 12 now they've got
they're doing articles
suspended from twitter over
uh you know tweet about a comment that
we should even be careful because we're
living in 1984 we came in well we worked
we'll we'll just focus on uh we got the
story from the daily wire as luke
mentioned matt walsh suspended from
twitter over transgender tweets here's
what twitter has censored i don't know
if we can actually show on youtube with
twitter even exactly isn't that type of
crazy world we're living in
but don't give i'll put it this way
don't give them the benefit of the doubt
on anything no
if they're gonna censor it assume it's
it's it's correct that's it i didn't i
have not read i have not yet read what
matt walsh said
it's right
yeah if they censored it don't care i'm
sick of these games they play
that twitter is very uh
all of these platforms are very
obviously in the bag in one direction
i don't know man look they're doing
they're using legality as an excuse when
ethically it's i don't think it's
ethical well it's only going policy
legally evil we got to understand we're
heading towards a very important
political time this is only going to
wrapping up this is only going to get
crazier more and more people are going
to get hit and they're slowly and surely
implementing a society where you get in
trouble for wrong thinking dude you can
mute matt walsh if you don't want to
listen to it you don't need to ban his
account exactly yeah if you don't want
to watch someone you don't have to
history his tweet refers to transgender
uh trans women as men that's that's the
gist of his tweet that's that's what it
was this is what you got into it with
jack dorsey about right the fact that
um the overwhelming majority of this
country does not agree with the leftist
view on gender uh gender critical
ideology yet twitter is enforcing a
fringe gender criticism calling like a
trans woman a man in his tweet or was he
just saying trans women are no he said
the uh
the the individual who won jeopardy a
four-star admiral he said they were all
men
and that's a bannable offense
now i suppose it's like stepping in the
fire and being like i can we can all
step in fire watch i've tweeted i've
tweeted a bunch of things people said
i'm gonna get banned for
and i just don't care but i said i
tweeted once um
males are better at women's sports than
females
and it got like thousands of retweets
and i'm like i don't is that am i what's
wrong with that statement right
and so i i think there's ways
to to like you know you can point this
out
the rules make no sense is basically
what i'm trying to get to i don't know i
don't i don't even understand it anymore
and and i'll say this too as it pertains
to youtube and the covet rules i don't
even know i have no idea what the co
because like they have all these rules
about what you can and can't say about
the vaccines and all that stuff but but
covet has has we've we've got so many
different variants of covet yeah i'm
like
does this rule pertain to delta omicron
lambda which one yeah which one does or
it doesn't because if they said
initially if you claimed vaccines wayne
and efficacy you'd get banned
but now it's like the whole narrative
for the booster so i'm like is that rule
still there i don't know it the whole
point is not to know or understand the
rules the point is just to make sure
that as soon as a new rule is in place
you follow it yes lock step no questions
asked yeah compliance no matter what and
the rules are no matter how insane it is
and it doesn't matter if you understand
it they don't like that yeah they're
kept vague on purpose so then the new
ceo can come in and reinterpret it and
then build it all that type of people so
that they can ban what they want
whatever they want
and it's like that that old saying like
you know you know when you see it you
can't define it but you know what you
see yes obscenity yeah yeah they they
don't want you to know exactly what the
rules are but they want you to know when
you're offending the regime
it is such a power play for them to be
like well we're not really going to tell
you exactly what you can or can't say
we're just going to pull the rug out
from you under you if today we decided
this is the wrong thing to say dude it's
so dirty you can easily ban an account
and never have to think of them again as
an admin but it's so easy to contact
them and let them know why it just takes
an extra step but it's so easy to not do
it like to be lazy and just be like yeah
they're just a words on a screen they're
not a real person i don't have to think
about it i'll just destroy their
livelihood how much you want to bet more
people are going to sign up for getter
you know they got over a million yeah oh
the amount of people signing up for a
getter hit like a million yeah not post
reported but there's a reason i also was
critical of getter and their kind of
vague generalized term services because
they're very similar terms of services
to a lot of these big tech outlets that
of course use and abuse them and if
you're
leaving a lot of leeway and saying just
trust us i'm sorry people have been
through enough already we need more uh
reassurances we need more transparency
we need more accountability and we need
a process where people actually
understand what's going on what are the
rules and and they keep them vague in
order to of course have that draconian
power over you because you never know
what you could say cnn gets to say
whatever they want they get to eat human
brains they get to show conflict they
get to show gore they get to exploit it
they get to show people dying every
single day
independent media gets to play by a
completely different set of rules that's
not even told to them and they get hit
and punished all the time which is
ridiculous reza oslon ate human brains
he ate human brains on tv looks like
marjory taylor green's back on twitter
did you guys see that what
14 hours ago
that's not true this is from yahoo news
i see her rep mtg account so tweeting
again interesting yahoo says she's back
yeah hey
rep mtg it might be just one of her two
accounts this is maybe her no she's got
her her her um official account has
always been up but her first didn't get
that i thought they were both banned
okay so now she's tweeting personally
from her official account i think just i
mean what else well i don't know how you
define what's i don't personal exactly
yeah they're like she's back and she's
tweeting again
well but she has that is there all the
whole all along rep mtg
yeah i was just checking her out get her
page she's up like 20 000 followers from
yeah i'm i'm up like 150 000 followers
so
the getter thing's weird because they
just copy your uh they like cloned
twitter i guess yeah it's weird so you
have followers but that's like no one
using those accounts for the most part i
don't even know if there are actual
accounts but they just like copy your
number
but when i jumped over to get her my
number went up like 150 000 people so
actually there's a lot of engagement
it's crazy and now they gained another
million users they're just creating uh
parallel uh cultures more and more and
more that's gonna be so good more people
are going to spin up new social networks
they can federate and just become part
of this this growing organism good and
bad i guess um the issue is
if we divide
and completely disassociate from each
other then we just become like warring
factions yeah we gotta unite
there needs to be some overarching
agreement in culture and it used to be
like you know the american constitution
or even like an rss search algorithm
where you can at least see what people
are posting on different websites
constitution will be more of a computer
code like we're going to rewrite some
sort of rules it'll be a computer rule
i think
or just allow people to have personal
responsibility and understand that they
have discernment and treat them like
adults i'm a grown ass man i don't need
big tech overlords telling me what i can
and cannot listen to that idea it's so
patronized it's such an establishment
elitist belief that hey you're too
stupid for your own good we need to tell
you what to believe it that's crazy the
fact that we're here at this point where
people are deciding what you can and
cannot discern for yourself is wild it's
ridiculous and it's disrespectful to
human intelligence and it's stopping
human progress because when you when you
limit ideas when you limit debate when
you limit conversations you stop human
beings from growing and being better and
i think this is why it's done
deliberately this is done to dumb us
down to enslave us to put us in fear to
have us controlled because every step of
the way that we're seeing this
implemented it's creating a situation
where you're afraid to even express
ideas over losing your livelihood and if
we're doing this and we're the ones who
are actually talking to the individuals
out there imagine what they're going
through and their limited perspectives
that are closely slowly slowly and
surely closing in to a limited
perspective that of course the global
elites want you to have that that's
exactly what's happening here when you
say they they're getting their
perspective squishy humanity by and
large on big tech social media on the
information highways the the the ideas
that they're allowed to express the cars
that are able to be on that highway are
limited and regulated more and more and
more where it's coming
where you know uniqueness is becoming
rarer yeah the covid one particularly
for me is really interesting because
it's first time i've ever lived through
what people have considered a pandemic
and i i would love to talk about it all
the things like what's right what's
wrong people saying the wrong thing but
in it like a place where i don't want
people to believe it when they see it
like that's up to you don't believe this
stuff and face value any of it that's
but listen to it definitely listen to it
i i need that it makes me i want to
listen to the kooky ideas i want to
listen to the crazy ideas i want to
listen to people's perspectives that are
not mine i want to listen to ideas that
broaden my perspective and my mind i
want to have an open mind i don't want
to be force-fed ideas spoon-fed things
that i have to believe in to fit into
society that's not the way i want to
live my life and my experience
controlled and regulated by some yuppie
with flip-flops drinking his starbucks
controlling what could go into my
perception in reality are you kidding me
i want to slap that starbucks thing out
of his hand immediately
shake them and be like let humanity be
free
release us from your conquest because
when you truly do release people when
you truly allow them to be free and to
make their own mistakes and to be
responsible for themselves only then do
we have some actual human progression
and when governments have been limited
when governments step out of the way
that's truly when we had the best
inventions the best progress and the
best thing that has happened to humanity
throughout recorded human history and
these people are standing in the way not
just of information but from human
progress and growth these people are
enemies of free humanity and they will
do anything in their way to subjugate
you and to conquest your existence and
your true potential i'm sick of it i'm
not going along with it and we're doing
everything we can to fight it but this
notion of open discourse cuts exactly
against the far left's idea of
pre-censorship because you know
censorship is just like take down a
tweet this tweet has been removed kind
of thing but going back to herbert
marcuse's uh who was the architect of
the far left in many regards he
advocated for pre-censorship the people
that have ideas that are
opposed to left-wing ideology
they cannot express those ideas because
those ideas can be poisonous so that
person cannot they have to be
pre-censored so those those ideas can't
exist and people can't even hear them
because if they hear them it could be
dangerous to the to the movement
so i mean and that's to their narratives
to their profit motives to their entire
story to their entire existence you
could break all of that with the truth
then let me ask you
do you think supreme court justice
sotomayor falsely claiming a hundred
thousand children are in serious
condition from covid was her being dumb
or evil that's she didn't just say that
let me let me let me add some things to
here too she also claimed that covet
debts are at an all-time high they have
been going down since september
according to the official data look it
up yourself she also said that omnicron
is deadlier than delta obviously no
scientific findings presenting that as
well so so i i i think
i i don't know dumb or evil
a combination of both well not
if you put yourself in a position of
power and you're and you're dumb and
you're ruling over people's existences
you should learn to shut the hell up
right so if you're dumb and you know
you're dumb and you're still dictating
how people should live you're dumb and
evil you're a combination of both i
don't i don't see dumb here i see
ignorant and i think there's a
distinction to be made there i think
that she could gen because like you read
the actual quotes that she said and i'm
just like this sounds like an aunt of
mine that just you know just overdoses
on blue pills and just watches you know
corporate press i mean she sounds like a
woman that is genuinely uninformed and
ignorant about what she's talking about
otherwise she wouldn't say that stuff
because to malevolently say this that
doesn't really add up for not as a
supreme court justice yeah
you'd be strung up for doing that yeah
i'm trying to mislead the american
public it sounds like what whoopi
goldberg was saying too that any new
variety any new variant of a virus is
more powerful which is blatantly not
true because you can have a variant of a
virus that's less powerful than before
she said deadlier i missed that quote
more powerful she said more powerful and
it was like whoopi
you're a passionate person that believes
the things you say so so make sure you
you know what you're well what you're
saying is right before you sorry i
thought you were talking about sonia
maybe maybe she's she's going off of the
the dragon ball z principle where goku
was very powerful then gohan was
stronger than goku at least in the cell
saga likely
that explains everything i understand
your train of thought
um
she was triple
whippy was triple vaxxed and got coveted
so she's like what is going on but then
she kind of slipped back into this
brainwashing variety variants are always
more powerful and the only way to stop
it is that well she said i did
everything i was told to do
why am i sick and that's a lot of
questions that a lot of people are
having especially in some of the most
vaccinated places all around the world
and there's a lot of serious questions
to ask there because there's a lot of
consequences that we can't even get into
but people will make up their own minds
not a medical doctor not here trying to
give you any kind of medical advice but
there's a lot of questions that are not
being answered by the medical
professionals that should absolutely
concern that every citizen let's bring
it back to the supreme court they're
listening to oral arguments on the
vaccine mandate
and either
these these liberal justices have no
idea what's going on
or they're deliberately misleading the
americans i'm going to call ignorance
and that's why i brought up whoopi
because she seemed very ignorant like
definitely not malicious what she was
saying she didn't know what she's saying
this is the person deciding if we're
going to have a vaccine mandate this is
the person controlling your life and
existence in the next few coming weeks
and months who's going to this year
exactly so this is this is the person
that's going to decide if you get to
live your life freely or if the
government's going to come in a way and
force a medication on you so do you
think that it's evil just because
they're making a decision because she's
in a position of power and i think you
know obviously with all the news reports
coming out right now i think she's going
to understand that she was definitely
wrong here
these people are evil
that's that's the conclusion here but
but if i it truly is just ignorance just
someone being a dumbass i think they're
going to realize sooner or later that
hey
hey you know someone near her is going
to say you were wrong about everything
clarence thomas asked
is the vaccine the only treatment for
kovid and that a lot of people are just
like that's a question wow that's a very
important because when it comes to
vaccine mandates the argument is osha
should have the ability to do this and
then a very simple question not for or
against just a clarifying question is
there is there anything else we can do
oh that's why i was shining on twitter
and yeah yeah just a simple question is
there anything else we can do i'm not
saying yes or no to the man thomas has a
really really powerful question and this
this question actually leads you to
another line of questioning
um i can't remember who mentioned this
but they said
you know what about all the other
diseases huh why is it just coven um i
can't remember who brought it up but
they were like what about the flu yes
and
they said oh but you know the flu
no there's no there's no answer so i
tweeted we should mandate everyone be
forced to get every vaccination that's
available in the united states i believe
the cdc lists 58 why not if one no not
why not all
clearly something doesn't make sense
when they're trying to mandate one and
not all because people do die from these
other other other illnesses
they have you can't have it both ways
so in the hospital they would require
people to get the flu vaccine or you
would have to wear a mask for the entire
flu season some nurses would refuse to
get the flu vaccine sometimes the flu
vaccine was not very effective because
it would go based off of australia's
virus and try to find a way to counter
the american virus as well didn't always
work very well i'm guessing that we're
going to end up seeing the same effect
with cobit but i'm curious if they're
going to make it for everyone or if
they're just well luke luke you were
saying that there's like they're saying
now that omicron may be like the final
variant or something well there's a lot
of medical professionals uh whether it's
in many european countries there's also
a lot of medical professionals coming
from south africa right now saying that
omnicron will be the final variant the
end of this pandemic this is something
that i was talking about the possibility
of a few weeks ago and there is some
early preliminary data suggesting that
because this virus is so transmissive
and because it's so less lethal than the
previous one for many of uh the category
groups here that it will run through the
population in a span of one month to
three months and therefore give everyone
natural immunity and therefore end the
pandemic from here and there's a very
small small chance it's extremely
unlikely that there's going to be a new
variant that's going to be more lethal
because of how uh this variant has
already taken over all the other
variants that's some of the early data
early information i was i was talking
about it for a while now
look what's happening right now in south
africa it gives us a lot of reason to be
hopeful
regarding your question from earlier to
tim about why don't we vaccinate for all
the vaccines at once there's this thing
called compounding that affects
compounding activities with um any kind
of medication so you can test you have
five different medications you test one
of them on someone you test the second
one on someone test third but you don't
know what they're gonna do when they're
test put in at the same time so that's a
completely unique test you need to do
and for every new drug that's added to
the mix that's another completely new
test and you've got to see how that
interacts with people well if bioshock
bioshock taught us anything it's that
people become splicers and they'll
slowly go crazier and develop
superpowers
there's also this report you guys have
you guys you guys know bioshock come on
yeah
there's also some reported um accounts
saying that there was a conversation
between justice kagan that asked what
risk do the unvaccinated workers pose to
others and uh you know i haven't
verified this myself but according to
some of the early statements we're
seeing here osha's own data shows that
it's unclear to exactly what extent uh
that question could be even answered if
this procedure even reduces transmission
this is not me saying it this is some of
the transcripts happening for me look at
this look at this
yahoo news justice sotomayor claims not
to understand the distinction between
between state and federal powers
this is insane let's talk about recall
powers for a minute wow dude i need the
context of this
supreme court justice sonia sotomayor
professed not to be able to understand
the distinction between federal
authority and state police powers during
oral arguments in a consolidated case
before the court on friday morning
critics including plaintiffs submit the
rule represents federal and bureaucratic
overreach quote i'm not sure i
understand the distinction why the
states would have the power to institute
a mandate such as osha's but the federal
government wouldn't stated the associate
justice
if um
we have to give a lesson on the ninth
and tenth amendment to our own supreme
court justices yo when i say the system
is collapsing y'all can't tell me i'm
wrong you can't have them in power for
40 years what is going on dude
it's idiocy it's idiocracy it's like
you've got a politician the secretary of
agriculture and they're like why would
you put water on plants yeah it's like
dude if you are in charge of it look at
p buddha judge it is idiocracy the the
he's a small town mayor they put him in
charge of transportation and then he
goes missing for several weeks
it's it is it is i'm sorry mike judge's
timeline of 500 years or whatever was
wrong it was like 10 years 10 years and
we found ourselves here come on donald
trump is in the wwe hall of fame he was
president mike you're a prophet but you
got your timeline way too far out it was
way sooner here we are i heard he's
doing another beefs on butthead yes yeah
i'm really excited about i'm excited
about that totally but michael he was i
mean idiocracy is becoming more of a
documentary by the day
especially with leaders like kamala
harris especially with just the
absurdity that we're seeing on the
corporate media and i think there's a
deliberate effort to dumb down the
average human being and let's let's be
real about something okay you guys have
all seen idiocracy i imagine yeah yeah
camacho was not a bad dude no he
recognized that uh luke wilson's
character was the smartest guy he brings
him in
and by hiring the right guy solved the
problem by getting the brondo off the
crops actually could have called the
movie meritocracy well they they first
put him in jail for being camacho didn't
camacho the president actually got him
out and was like let's do this and so i
gotta say he may have been a wwe hall of
famer as the president he may not have
been the smartest guy but he made some
good moves that ultimately benefited his
country and donald trump may not have
been the greatest guy he may have been a
wwe hall of famer he may not have been
the smartest guy but he did some
policies that were really helping out
look at that idiocracy come true um i'm
afraid that there's forces that are
attempting to shatter our government
and uh
i don't know we do you think term limits
getting you guys like these people out
of here uh supreme court justice and
congressman is going to help uh no
this whole entire system is absolutely
crooked it's absolutely rotten to its
core and it's and it's only it only
profits off of people's ignorance and
this is why i think there's the
deliberate effort to dumb people down
and to normalize this kind of videocracy
that we have been seeing instituted
almost every step of the way with
mainline establishment culture mainline
establishment politics mainline
establishment society it all
incentivizes you being a dumb cod of the
machine going along with of course the
bull crap that it spews was there a
period in american history where you
liked the american government where you
thought it was functioning
you're asking me if i like government
all right
that's that's that's a question that i
think it's very self-evident i don't
like any kind of you know government or
authority or centralization or or top
down control of people's free existences
and and that to me is just yeah my
perspective my personality uh because if
you look at the us government especially
from its you know onset there's a lot to
to criticize there especially with its
imperialistic kind of endeavors
especially with its foreign policy
there's a lot of things that of course
you could criticize uh but there's also
a lot of things that you could
complement with especially the united
states at least representing the ideas
of free speech of being able to defend
yourself and even though it's not
perfect i think it's one of the freest
best places in the world uh right now
standing up against this global tyranny
and i think that's why there has been
such a concerted effort trying to bring
it down destroyed from the inside
because it still represents this bastion
of freedom that is standing in the way
from total totalitarianism total
totalitarianism and technocratic
overlords controlling every uh existence
uh every every part of our existence
that we have but don't you want to be in
the pod yeah yeah
you know what's funny is that literally
everything they're presenting to us is
the matrix like in the pod eating bugs
you will be you'll be hooked into a pod
plugged into the metaverse yo they're
literally describing the matrix yeah
they're like join the matrix you'll like
it the new york post ran an article
highlighting how some cows were given
virtual reality so they could at least
feel like they're outside
my tagline was like this is going to be
your future you're the cow
this is what they're doing this is
literally what they're doing they're
creating a digital heroine which they're
calling the metaverse that they're gonna
have you licked in through through your
elon musk microchip and there's going to
be no understanding of what is real and
what is not when they control every
aspect of your consciousness
you're going to be literally uploading
your consciousness to mark zuckerberg's
private
playland and when you're in that
metaverse the the ability for them to
subjugate you is absolutely astounding
and i think that's why they're going
forward with this kind of larger
metaverse plan this larger virtual
reality and when they develop artificial
intelligence um especially with the
advancements that they had with quantum
computing game's over for for humanity
are you guys going to plug into the
metaverse 100 yeah i'm already in yeah
i'm on something called decentraland
uh it's it's pretty addictive it's crazy
is it it's a virtual reality yeah it's
basically like a giant chatroom that you
walk around in and can interact with
with like are you using kiosks no i was
just on the mouse and keyboard because
we like the oculus is super cheap and so
we've got it and that space pirate game
is so much fun it's amazing that's how
they get you though man
like you you you get this like laser
sword and a shield and you're like
swatting robots and then you can switch
to the gun and you're pew pew shooting
lasers at the robots it's a fun game and
they've also got in the oculus this
virtual chat world where i don't
remember what it's called but you can
pick your avatar you can be any kind of
weird you can be a carrot you know i
bring it up because i saw a guy walking
around he was a kid and i'm like this
guy really wanted to be that
my guy was like a generic looking guy i
guess i don't know i don't know
but you walk around and i guess i don't
know if this is the way it's set up but
my understanding is that as you talk
when you walk closer to people you get
louder in their headset and when you
walk away is that how it works something
like that yeah yeah that's cool although
i didn't i had the sound off when i was
in decentralized what mystical made up
creature or you in the meta verse
are you a hippie
yeah yeah yeah also they have cryptos
that they tie to these websites so
decentraland has one called mana and
basically they're prepping for a future
where you use a cryptocurrency as the
in-game currency
and it's going to be you play to earn
and they're going to have two
six-year-olds and eight-year-olds in
there for 10 hours 12 hours a day like
basically new age slave labor and we're
gonna have to build laws to protect kids
against dude mark zuckerberg is going to
be your boss like he's going to be your
president overlord yeah supreme overlord
of your consciousness check it out check
it out look where we already are people
are building businesses in the digital
landscape i knew a guy who he sold some
product i remember what he sold but he
was completely dependent on the google
algorithm that when people searched for
something in his area google would show
him first the algorithm changed one day
and it knocked him down several several
spots and his business stopped all of a
sudden he couldn't get he couldn't get
any sales and he was worried
people build businesses on youtube
youtube bans you because you don't have
the right politics you lose your money
you're excised from society imagine what
the metaverse is going to be like what's
that you've broken one of the rules
because you said a naughty word mark
zuckerberg removes you completely from
the metaverse and now you can't make
money at all or you'll see not even that
not even that your brain chip
wrong thing he's committing a a crime of
thinking something against the
establishment take him down take him out
he's thinking about he's thinking about
doing something unsavory we're gonna
move his kiosk to a further location
away from central land and then you're
like oh what have i done and you're
waiting for like 24 hours for your
ticker to go down so you can get moved
back to your regular spot no you'll be
back but then you think another thing
and you get banned for seven days you
can't even be in the digital cool live
they want you in there still they don't
want you to leave so they're going to
like punish you but try and keep you in
you're going to be in the digital ghetto
for just thinking the wrong thought
you know you know you know what they'll
do you know they'll do we talked about i
talked about this we're doing
brainstorming sessions on how to deal
with like people who post awful trash on
the internet that's legal but you know
because obviously if someone's posting
illegal imagery or illegal illegal
content threats and stuff you
you ban them but if someone's posting
stuff that's like obscene we were like
you create an underbelly uh
if they violate the rules so many times
they just get sent to an area where
people can post whatever they want right
because like we're not going to
australia yeah like australia we're not
going to ban
and communicate with people but you
clearly
you know want to post things that people
don't want to see
like i think in the metaverse if you
break the rules enough they'll just send
you to another dimension no yeah a
prison circle change the dimension to a
prison version of the world and you'll
be in a server with a really low income
no one in there can buy your product
like they're all poor people who can
barely afford your product and you will
just all of a sudden be poor in the
metaverse you will be happy chris will
be happy what's your uh uh vr uh
representation what are you gonna go as
as i well not nothing nothing i am so
analog i was born in rural kentucky you
know
i have i don't know mark zuckerberg i
don't like it
i'm not plugging it mark zuckerberg
comes here with a vr headset and a
firearm saying listen you got to pick uh
a person an alternate reality and a
different personality right now put on
the headset where are you it could be a
carrot
you could be a potato you could be
whatever you want
gun to my head i'm gonna go with my
spirit animal the beaver okay yeah i'll
be a beaver what actually happens is
mark zuckerberg walks in
and he's like uh you guys have to put on
these headsets and if you don't i've got
a gun and everyone put them on now and
then we're like all right mark calm down
we all put him on mark and then mark
pulls out his laptop and he's like you
actually don't get to choose in the
metaverse i'm gonna turn luke into a
giant rabbit and i'm gonna make ian the
carrot and then you guys are like no
what's happening to us
luke looks at his hands and he's like
i'm a rabbit now
and mark is just in control
my my character would probably just be
like a wireframe guy
you know like that's cool hey the
furries they're gonna be the first ones
on this there you go i'm pretty sure
they're no no
go in there it's like people who have
identity issues are like going in there
and they're doing this for these for
these reasons i'll bet there could be a
conspiracy even surrounding that when we
get to the point where your neural link
chipped and think about how crazy this
could be you you get the neuro link
installed and now metaverse is actually
you in a digital world where you can
touch and feel and sense things and they
can they can inflict pain on you they
can be like oh you're being punished
press a button and you go ah it hurts
like they can actually hit your brain
they can they they can do freak they can
make pain friction right so it's a very
low grade pain if you start walking
towards a boundary it slowly starts
hurting and you're like oh and you stop
and back off they can do screwed up
stuff to you once they get inside your
brain man linda what's your character my
character is going to be myself or mark
zuckerberg that's my plan that's who i
want to go on
you can't be me
i'm me
yeah you how do you know mark how do you
know you're you oh my gosh philosophical
questions that's what i would do i don't
know um i really one day there's a virus
and like everyone turns into trump and
they're running around
i don't know
what am i like all of the trump
supporters would be laughing and
high-fiving each other and all the left
would be like
and then mark would be like today there
was a problem where everyone turned into
trump and we're really sorry we're
working to get it fixed but just hang
tight and beat trump for a few hours and
we'll get it sorted
you can't log out you're in the pod
people are banging on these things
what it feels like
they can't okay i'm in i like it i like
it now
i believe that we really shouldn't have
anyone in control of this thing kind of
like a network like a phone network or
roads like no one owns the roads in the
united states it's just kind of a system
that everyone uses that where
the roads go there are some private
roads there's international spanish
companies that literally are putting
tolls on american roads but there should
be politicians selling the the rights
that's messed up but there should be a
freeway of of uh of metaverse i think
that everyone can kind of use it will
our taxes
keep it up keep it going keep it
transparent no because the absolutely
not there's a lot of value to augmented
reality the speed that you can navigate
through information is valuable you know
adaptability yeah
they're live they're going to have
metaverse prison
like there's this movie i watched i
forgot it's called where they invent
this nanotechnology that they put in
your eye
and then it creates memories in your
mind and so what they do is they they
want to make it so that if someone's got
a five year prison term they just sit
you down put an eye dropper in your eye
and then it implants five years of
prison into your brain
and so you're like in your mind in
prison and there's no people and it's
like solitary basically how was the
black mirror episode was it a black
mirror episode i think so yeah yeah sure
yeah i remember this lady was like in
this little tiny white box and it feels
like a million years she's being
punished maybe yeah it's like uh was
that black mirror watch it again how
about we go to super chats if you
haven't already smash that like button
subscribe to the channel share the show
with your friends become a member at
timcast.com to support our work and our
efforts keep our journalists employed
and keep this show running let's see
what you guys got
we got uh for some reason youtube always
blocks out the name of the first person
but they say they wrote recorded a song
called the news you will absolutely love
tim it's a five-minute political rock
opera inspired by your work soundcloud
uh i guess what is it i can't read what
the name is unfortunately
sounds like american idiot check spin
the ufo for a link at 8 pm all right we
will check that out rock opera gf says
jesus is lord thank you for the super
chat thank you red rum says marry me
luke oh he was in the bathroom he didn't
he's too bad it's too bad he might have
heard you though nat says is it linda or
lydia
ha ha it is linda when luke is referring
to me it is lydia when anyone else is
referring to me
lydia
because
your
says linda for some reason
all right
das crush says tim long time viewer love
the show can you talk about what's going
on in kazakhstan saw street videos where
there was a lot of shooting going on do
you know what's going on there because i
i've only saw a few stories oh no i
don't civil unrest the government you
know i was i was watching this clip and
it's like the military joining in with
the protesters
and i don't think people understand
especially like activists how difficult
it is to deal with mass unrest
let's say you're you know you're a
president of a country or something and
you have a hundred thousand people
across your country protesting and it's
getting violent
now if most people in the country of
millions do not want a revolution
do you stand up against the
revolutionaries and if you do because it
could get lethal what do you do so this
is what happens in kazakhstan you know
the president apparently is like we're
gonna stop these violent terrorists and
we're gonna use any force necessary and
russia is now coming in and helping the
government but the people who are
protesting are like yo this is a corrupt
government
so what do you do when most people don't
want the change i don't know i don't
have the answers
if i saw anti like if antifa went out
and were riding like crazy and then all
of a sudden a bunch of foreign
government said the us government is
illegitimate because there are
protesters out there we'd be like yo not
the no not no way these people are nuts
but they were massive black lives matter
protests
so imagine if people around the world
were like yeah we're going to give them
those people power of your government
wow we'd be freaking out you have to
assess the merits of the protests which
is really difficult to do but i mean
you know i mean like black lives matter
there it would be very difficult to
assess whether or not their demands were
credible
but at the same time you know we are a
protest nation and we have been since
you know we
came to this country and established the
united states of america so
it's it's difficult it's tricky to say
scott says hey tim recently had to leave
a job protecting one of the tech
billionaires for the vax but after last
night's show i know what i must do
protect ian at all costs yes yes i'd
love to see what i can offer to the
people and the great state of
fredamastan
yeah afridamastan is going to be real
interesting we're hopefully going to
have the new facility built in it should
be completely done in six months
it should be operational in six months
it won't be completely done for several
months after that because
the the first thing we're going to have
is we have it's a it's a 75 by 100 foot
building
it's going to be three stories basically
and we're going to have on the second
store the second floor
is going to be this studio so for the
most part the building's going to be
completely open 36 feet high it's crazy
and 100 feet back and then 75 by 2025 is
the green room in the studio that's
going to be operational hopefully within
six months
then the rest of the facility all the
stuff outside which is going to be like
rock climbing wall foam pit editing bays
a kitchen that stuff's got to be built
over time yeah the green screen the
green screen room yeah we're going to
set up a green screen corner so like
probably underneath the studio it's
going to be all green and well lit you
guys want to make movies with us so that
we can we can record full green screen
everything and and make fun stuff
yeah yeah so we'll be building that out
plus we still do have this facility this
is where a bunch of other new shows are
going to be
so we'll still use this studio fairly
often though like uh
you know we're not abandoning out right
and then people are still working and
editing here and we're still gonna have
the castle but now we're going to have
another location we're going to be
hiring like crazy and it's going to be a
whole lot of fun man and it's a great
way to stay in shape yeah
all right dc
ian i would like to volunteer tech
expertise to the problem of app store
gatekeeping especially if you know
anyone who might be considering an
alternative app store solution on
android yeah it's a big big thing i'm
thinking i want to make a decentralized
app store and i'd love to get it
pre-loaded on the freedom freedom
phone's questionable because we haven't
been able to rip them apart yet but i
like the the concept of preloading
something like that on a phone and that
stuff may already be out there so if you
can find the code um message me on
twitter and let me know that you're the
one that and i'll send you a link to our
chat room maybe you can help us build
that all right
bad adams says i live in frederick
maryland in the frederick maryland area
and i really need to know where you got
those 24 sliders it sounded so good also
i'm really glad all of you there are
okay you sh uh your show and luke's show
give me hope for the future glad to hear
it um it's a it's a it's a secret
location where we got these sliders man
you got to understand top top secret but
i'm gonna let you guys in on it it's
called ruby tuesdays
top secrets
uh went on grubhub and ruby tuesdays
popped up and i was like slider sliders
and
we got sliders and wings uh pretty good
i mean i got i got to say like actually
it was a pretty good burger you know it
wasn't like it didn't it didn't come off
like a freezer burger it seemed real
simple and uh thank you for the support
we were doing our best
yeah
mike says luke please talk about
harrison bergeron and brave new world
1984 is now the distraction also please
make another snack shirt with a giant
picture of snek women think he's cute
so uh okay yeah there's the big top
we'll do a big snack
snack adventures we'll do it we'll do we
can do we can do a similar design but we
can move the words in so we can do like
step on snack then snack and then and
find out it looks more like a worm yeah
he's adorable
he's awesome yeah it's supposed to be
uh angry but cute so it seems harmless
it comes across i like it we sell those
shirts like crazy it's it's nuts yeah i
mean we we don't even shout out that
often but people are buying them like
crazy i guess we got a good one great we
could if we could figure out how to make
sure it's like that all the time you
know that'd be great
no
no don't do it
i don't like the snake
the snake is taking
money out of my future seven children's
mouths
so
all right sarah says there's a media
report about it was the first article i
googled if swatting was legal in md it
lists some personal details so please be
uh be careful y'all love the show
there's a story i know that like a bunch
of uh places wrote about but like local
news wrote about the swatting i guess
they would oh interesting yeah i don't
know if you want to like google it or
someone wants to google it i saw rt do a
story about it oh i'm sure i have alerts
set up and so i see a bunch of stories
wrote about it but it was only like
right wing outlets that wrote about it
you know i guess the left was talking
about it but they don't care all that
much probably because they did it
i don't know
yeah we'll see i mean look if i had to
make a bet i would say it's probably
some like antifa type
that that was doing it actually i'd hit
that back i take that back i don't think
it was probably an establishment
democrat type like a karen like a very
pro
you know a very pro pelosi very pro
kamala angry we're hosting marjorie
taylor green we've had steve bannon and
they're just like
and they call in or whatever but it was
a dude so
i'm assuming it was a dude or someone
using a voice changer man maybe
yeah
i'm not seeing it
you're not saying anything yeah no i
looked earlier a bunch of uh right-wing
websites yeah yeah nothing new yeah top
gundy says i like carl benjamin's way of
forcing businesses to fight against the
osha mandates oppose the mandate comply
with masks for a short time and become
very well knowledged with osha safety
practice
i completely agree
i guarantee you if you go into a
restaurant you will easily see osha
violations because it's impossible
impossible and so imagine this imagine
you walk into a restaurant and they're
like excuse me you have to wear a mask
and then you're like oh okay and then
you're like oh i couldn't help but
notice that you're in violation of you
know page 23 section 7 of osha's federal
mandates i'm going to have to report you
unless you fix that right now what are
they going to do
nothing it's a restaurant they don't
follow any rules trust me take it from
me i promise restaurants are the
nastiest places in the world i've worked
in enough of them and i i can tell you
firsthand that none of the rules are
followed yeah
the the issue is
if we're at a point where they're so
terrified of inspectors coming in and
getting fined you can variously be like
i can get you're going to be fine for
that that and that just fix it right now
you you put pressure on you say look
make them live up to their own rules yes
that's one of the rules for radicals
that's correct make your opponent live
up to their own rules if these
businesses want vax mandates and they
want mask mandates
people look if you go to a restaurant in
chicago i love this one they're like if
you're in a city that has a vaccine
mandate when you walk in and they say do
you have your vax card like i do but can
i first make sure all of you guys have
your vax cards because they're not going
to have them right
because they're going to be like oh wait
what and be like well
i i'm i'm worried about you guys having
covid too of course so have you guys
been tested yeah no so you might have
covid
put them up to it make them follow their
own rules you'll you'll find it really
funny when you walk into a restaurant
they're like before you can come in you
need to prove a vaccination be like oh
absolutely absolutely thank you so much
for doing this because i'm so concerned
about this illness now can you have your
staff all show me and prove to me that
your cooks can you have your chef come
out right now and show me his card
you can't why not
yeah why can't you do that the first
move just my personal advice ask for the
manager there's a nine points there's a
99.7 chance that that manager is totally
incompetent and you will win this
argument
on having them produce their cards or
whatever oh just on an argument i mean
they're definitely not going to produce
their cards but just just by engaging a
manager in a restaurant there is a huge
chance that they are totally incompetent
and they're probably going to seat you
anyway they might actually produce their
cards to be fair they might i mean look
because in order to be in the buildings
you need one but how much you want to
bet when they have like a a you're at a
small diner and they're they're
enforcing the vax mandate because they
don't want to get in trouble but what
happens when like the the the diner had
to be opened at 5 00 a.m first six
o'clock the doors are open at six the
the chef the cook has to come in at five
there's no manager there he walks and
unlocks the door walks in the back turns
the other now starts getting things
clean didn't bring anything with him
because there's no one to check him
it's very likely people are going to be
lacks they're not going to be following
all the rules and you can be like i want
to make sure before i eat here that you
guys are taking this seriously and if
they can't produce them then what
so i've just been sent a screenshot from
the washington county sheriff's office
here where we are
and they are talking about our swatting
incident from last night they made a
media release about it it's relatively
long they go through the whole thing
they were like the property owner did
not give permission to enter the
building but due to the exigent nature
of this call they felt they had to go in
and just do a sweep of the building um a
check of the address was conducted it
was verified that no one was hurt or
threatening suicide upon completion of
the check of the address deputies left
the property the washington county
sheriff's department takes swatting
incidents seriously this incident
remains under investigation so i'm very
curious what happened where can i hear
it is right up there you saw it where at
the very top swatting incident yes yeah
over there to the right this oh look at
that
we're on tv
uh okay washington county sheriff's
office um oh yeah apparently there might
be personal information in there so uh
well like it's too late now it's it's
there because oh sorry my bad i put it
up i didn't realize yep uh multiple
deputies in the sheriff's office and
surrounding agencies responded the
incident while deputies were still in
route a member of the maryland state
police arrived at the property and
advised the call could be a swatting
incident a swatting incident is a false
9-1-1 call reporting a serious incident
upon arrival deputies were advised that
a live stream podcast was currently
being broadcast the property owner did
not give law enforcement permission to
enter the address that's right without a
warrant given the accident circumstances
a 9-1-1 call was made stating that two
people had been shot and other was
threatening suicide deputies advised
they were going to check the address and
confirm the safety of the occupants a
check of the address was conducted and
it was verified that no one was hurt or
threatening suicide upon completion of
the check of the address deputies left
the property the washington county
sheriff office takes swatting incidents
seriously the incident remains under
investigation and that's what lydia
basically just read
yeah so there you go to all of the crazy
people the first thing that was really
funny was the people claiming that we
staged it like there was no swatting
because you couldn't really see much
other than a person walking past right
and i'm like okay so then i took a
screenshot from the security cameras and
tweeted it out like there you go yeah
then you had people saying well
i think he called them i'm like i'm on
the show well then his staff did y'all
are nuts what is wrong with you people
that's ridiculous you've been planning
this for years too oh my gosh
i think he's been planning this for
months yeah no good stuff that's so
that's crazy that there's a release on
this and it's like kind of stupid that
they published our address yeah i'm like
i didn't i'm sorry i didn't notice that
before i put it up my bad yeah whatever
linda i know terrible linda but they're
like think about what these cops are
doing they're like someone is
threatening these individuals here's
their address like are you crazy
and you want to cooperate with these
people vulnerable spot which is on his
lower back these are ian's friends
[Laughter]
all right man let's try and let's try
and read some more super chats
okay
man of culture says speaking of the gulf
of tonkin an arms shipment from the us
headed to saudi arabia got intercepted
in yemeni waters by the hootie rebels
the uh the thing is who ships arms
unescorted into enemy territory
oh like were they they intended for it
to be taken still crazy how there's a
there's still a proxy war happening in
yemen um it's absolutely nuts that's how
that's happening right now dude i've
heard that the yemen
fiasco is the greatest humanitarian
crisis ever well luke says that all the
time not ever but currently right now
it's being
you know recognized by many
international organizations as one of
the worst um you know acts
against humanity since of course a lot
of people are being denied food
medication and basic access to clean
drinking water
so there's been a lot of children that
have been hurt extensively by this
the united states is on the side of
saudi arabia and al qaeda in that
specific region and a lot of the
hobbyists so all right firepower says
today's my birthday the best gift i got
was the mtg episode and the fact that
y'all are safe i keep you on my prayers
also screw the nwo um yeah marjorie
taylor green's definitely coming back
she was she was amazing to have on the
show it was fantastic and i was the the
member segment was just so much fun it
was getting really spicy and like it
felt so authentic i was like we gotta do
more really she she was she had to she
had to go on laura ingram so then it was
really cool because when she was doing
her interview on fox she's sitting in
the same chair and you can see like the
background is clearly our studio i was
hoping you would photobomb did you jump
in and you're like what's up we're
professionals here
that would be that would be so awful to
do with them and needy top trending on
twitter i mean yeah you'd be trending
and then they'd never come back and
everyone want to talk to you hilarious
yeah no maybe not we had a blast and uh
so many people i talked to were like i
thought she was nuts and then we
listened to her and it was like she
seems like a regular person who's angry
with congress and like the the like
nothing getting done
and i keep hearing from people they were
like when she mentioned forcing them to
come down and actually vote on bills
everyone was like that that's that's the
the the most positive response i get
people saying that was awesome i still
think about it yeah i know she's like i
don't just want a handful of people to
say yeah you know make them all come in
and they're like okay because you can't
and then everyone's like we have to do
our jobs
what are you getting paid for these
people i swear a hundred was it 174 000
a year and they don't even show up for
their jobs to vote must be because
they're getting on the phone fundraise
they're doing lobby meetings i can't
stand congress man that's why nobody
likes these people
yeah whatever totally busted system yeah
like they're too easy to bribe yeah
all right
taj says governor jay inslee of
washington state is pushing legislation
that will make it a crime to lie about
the integrity of the election rooting
out the dissenters well uh to be honest
that probably won't pass first amendment
muster so i'm not really worried that
the problem is with these decrees and
these laws is that you have to deal with
them until the courts can get rid of
them
so you'll see despots be like i'll just
decree it and then sue me
and that's where it's scary
all right um jay just posted some salt
awesome
thank you
what does that even mean
salty is like i'm unhappy ah yeah true
it's like or or like i have a burning
inside me a little cranky caused by this
salt
i think that's what it means correct me
brick muppet says soda mayor dumb or
evil tim embrace the healing power of
the word and
oh there you go i love it
there you go all right
all right raymond g stanley jr says luke
yes sir for all we saw this live for the
members event imagine luca going off in
person in real life luke you're doing
work and we thank you well thank you i
appreciate it yeah that was so much fun
at that we had a small event at the bar
i went wild on that i was
people there's people i could talk to in
real life
you know not online and i don't know i
just felt like a current and just went
off very exciting
mary says i've heard you reference the
movie v for vendetta if i can challenge
you now to read mark 12 28 to 29 and see
if you can get the real meaning of the
movie oh all right absolutely yeah we'll
check that out that sounds fun
uh alan says you all need to read the
real anthony fauci by robert kennedy jr
you will have your eyes open and feel
like certain individuals that are
mentioned in the book should be in jail
yeah we've already uh we've covered some
stories about children experimentation
and stuff like that and i'm already not
too uh
keen on the freedom of particular
individuals yeah orphanage children
monkeys beagle puppies you name it doubt
dr fauci has had his um
i don't even know where to go where
crafty says hey tim long time fan so tim
what's a guy got to do to get that sword
on the wall behind you i've always been
curious where you got it from ah top
secret location yeah uh local shopping
mall ah that's it very secret walked
into the mall and they had the they have
the
the master sword lynx master sword and i
was like that's cool master sword i'll
take it and he was like all right if it
was like i think it was like i don't
know 30 bucks or something and then i
was like oh that that little sword looks
cool too and i was like what's that from
he's like i don't know it's he's like a
ball sword and i'm like i'll take it
that's it it's a mole sword
and then we we put it on the wall and
it's cool right ian's got the whatever
that thing is called what is that called
some it's kind of sort of geometric uh
spirit geometry how many points does it
have what is that like a 64 tetrahedron
and a flat plane
he had just noted male 1
for all the
64
i've been thinking about some new
backgrounds and
wondering i have these comics i've got
the infinity gauntlet series sitting on
the table in front of me i might put
these up behind me someday those are
valuable aren't they yeah yeah well
comics aren't really valuable now with
ebay it's so easy to they used to be
rarity used to be a thing but yeah
they're like i don't know it's like 100
bucks for these six comics and i want to
show the world this is when comics were
phenomenal yes oh yeah can you pull up
the wide shot
oh yeah i can here we can show everybody
who's watching live the whole table and
you can see how how how ridiculous it is
like i have so much people have like
nothing that i have so much stuff yeah
so there's a gorilla in the middle of
the table yep there's the gorilla
there's there's ian you can see his
pyramid his rose
yeah these rocks everywhere
it's tim's spearmint technically i think
he came home with this one we bought a
bunch of rocks
really nice this is a ruby this is an
actual ruby
mined out of the earth it's the only one
that i have that was mined the other
ones they're making in laboratories
this is worth getting a close-up on one
day maybe i'll do it on the cast cast
that's cool though we have a bunch of
really cool rocks with something called
tv stone and it's like a fiber optic
stone you can put and it magnifies it's
really really crazy and then we've got
one that's um it's called like nor
sunstone or something and it creates
like a double vision anyway let's read
some more and i'm the crazy hippie
crystal
that's true all right brian noll says
luke i hope there will be no more
variants but glenn beck was on his show
today and he caught omicron after having
a cold so unfortunately i think they
will keep mutating like rhinovirus yeah
man we'll see some people say it's going
to be an endemic but
time will tell i hope you know my
guess is going to be correct cubicle
says ian i heard you say you liked mtg
the other night and he plans to start
streaming some paper magic oh my god
what is your play style or favorite
color combos and i gotta stop
there that's a reference to magic the
gathering the card game and not margery
taylor not the lady blue is my favorite
color by far i like control blue and
what
i think just blue blue
green blue and red blue and white
i don't like blue and black um blue's so
nasty blue is controlling the game it's
almost like distorting the rules
themselves tim and i made two blue decks
and we were just going at it and it was
like whoever got the manic [ __ ] first
one we'd just start over
too much power
but let me let me explain
there's a card game called magic the
gathering it's i think it's the first
card game ever made it's a strategy game
and uh people often say mtg in reference
to marjorie taylor green which then
immediately invokes magic the gathering
and ian and i both play it but uh uh
yeah it's it's it's a strategy game it's
like the first collectible card game
chess and poker combined is the easiest
way to expect it's great and we had
considered doing like a magic game but
it takes it's time consuming to be
honest me and tim used to sit down for a
couple hours after the show or
at night and play but we're doing more
stuff now a lot more work all right mark
s says we need to show with luke malice
and dave smith would be epic to see that
conversation i want to i want that us
debating statist if there's some kind of
status that wants to come on and counter
us let's do this and i would love that
because otherwise we'll just like yeah i
agree yeah i agree i don't want no i
think what would happen is we would try
to
no i'll anarchist each other
the camera would just be on any one of
the three and they would be like shaking
and staring at each other they would
start vibrating and then be sucked into
each other to form the ultimate
anti-status yeah that's the um what's
that force called when two things come
so close together that they snap towards
each other it's like in dragon ball z
when they had the earrings more dragon
ball z references the better
all right let's see
matt says hot take shooter was a better
was better as a tv show with ryan felipe
philip is that he said than the mark
wahlberg movie i did not see that but
perhaps
perhaps all right let's see we got a
bunch of new super chats just jumped in
rds i cannot believe the sheriff's
department docks your address i would be
pissed yeah
yeah but i'll be honest we got doxxed a
long time ago oh yeah it's the casimir
effect that's when two things get so
close and then they just because there's
a vacuum between them the vacuum is a
low pressure thing and they get snapped
together that's what happened to you and
dave that's what would happen and
michael malus
try way
cody says i've seen two orbs fly by tim
every time he talks about the incident
really
that's are you big
yeah talk i've been studying the
military's investment in talking plasma
where they're actually focusing lasers
into a point and creating like a a
floating piece of light i don't think
necessarily that when we see
orbs that that's what that is but for
all i know it could be an alien shining
a laser at us it could just be
dust
it could be a bug
like a microorganism i don't know
what do you think it is luke
don't get me started do you think that
there's like aliens or some sort of like
certain one oh yeah definitely
what do you think even orbs you think
what do you think orbs would be some
sort of interdimensional energy
yeah
yeah i like these plasm plasmon surface
plasmon it's like these these things
that are at the center of plasma clouds
and it seems like light bounces off of
them and then causes the plasma clouds
to move almost like a sentient
structure
well then
let's talk
honor says hi hi from australia i've
been in lockdown for two years how the
hell am i supposed to get into a
relationship if i can't take a girl out
to a cafe i'm so angry and have no hope
for the future i'm so lonely bro brutal
and sad to hear it there's a video
out of new zealand of this woman and
she's like she's dancing she's like i
just got my blue bracelet so now i can
walk in the parking lot no for real and
they let her walk around the parking lot
and back at the quarantine zone and
she's like dancing and all excited like
yes i got my bracelet and i'm just like
man whoa good dog yeah essentially
you're absolutely right uh for that
person leaving the comment you don't
have to go to a coffee shop go to a park
uh go on nature walks try to go out and
um you know explore areas as much as you
can but at the same time
you know you got to stand up for
yourself and your personal liberty and
your freedom as much as you can
i found it
when you play the long game and put
yourself on the internet um speaking
your truth like who you are for real and
you you kind of put yourself out there
that people find you that are good for
you so that's but that's the long game
but it does seem to work or just you
know go to a protest and meet other
people who are like-minded like you who
are fed up with everything that they're
doing all right we'll do one more right
here we got ember in the night he says
tim when are we going to sit down for a
game of magic
okay so here's what we're hoping
we actually we actually wanted to have
members be able to come to the compound
come to the studio and compound studio
on like a friday night where we would
have like 10 people you'd sign up if you
were a member to the website then we'd
be like here's the waiting list it's
massive and then we would do like a mix
of waiting list and like auction and we
can't do that out here maryland isn't as
fun but the new facility i think we're
going to be able to do that
and we can definitely do games of magic
the gathering
and i will just warn you guys you will
be completely annihilated we need to
play like a draft format or something
because otherwise tim's ian well the
cheeky deck is insane it's not even that
but ian and i have have have decks in
this game we went so hard here's the
people that understand this game imagine
the gathering it's a strategy game it's
been around for what almost 30 years now
in 1993 so there's an absurd amount of
cards
there's technically a lot of rules now
but if if you're not if you're familiar
with this game i'll just uh you know you
don't need to hear this but for those
that aren't
it's just it's a competitive game where
you you go up against someone else it's
imagine it's like playing chess but you
have your own custom chess board and ian
and i have our own custom decks that are
so insanely powerful that we just
stopped playing
that's what happened where we started we
started just rolling the dine whoever
got the high number one yep it was like
i rolled at seven and then ian's like i
roll the ten good game you win you want
to cut yeah just play win all right i'm
gonna shuffle uh but for those that are
fans of the game you'll have a blast too
many many problems we all have mana we
had like nine mana crypts we were like
let's invest we're trying to figure out
what to invest in in the early days i
think magic cards is a good move it
actually is it's outperformed the s p
500 these tr these collectible cards
because uh but for those aren't familiar
with any of these cards don't worry
about the names of them just know that
when ian names it's like it's something
powerful it's like a really good thing
but i'll just i'll just say
one of the decks that i have every card
that can be holographic foil is except
for the older cards which are even more
expensive because they're extremely rare
and then i put them in golden sleeves
gauntlet of might you accidentally got a
gauntlet of might accidentally no i you
accidentally got the the older one or
something no i i bought on purpose okay
yeah i've been playing magic since since
like since i was a real little kid i'm
such a big fan
so i wanted to just get a bunch of
really good old cards and i made a deck
that's ridiculous it's so good and it's
really good too it's too good all right
everybody for those that aren't familiar
with it thanks for sitting here and
listening you know we uh
we were going to actually have a music
performance tonight but i guess the
weather the snow hit we're in the middle
of nowhere so the roads aren't that good
and michael was unfortunately able to
make it i mean hopefully we can get out
here at some point because you know it
would be it'd be fantastic and you know
he's michael graves from the misfits he
couldn't make it so no no performance
but i guess we'll wrap it up there go
sign up at the website timcast.com and
help support our work
check out the green room episode if you
want to see all the behind the scenes
stuff with marge retailer green when
when she showed up and when we when
we're showing around the studio and
everything like that and it's a
membership supports our journalists
smash that like button subscribe to this
channel follow us on timcast irl on
instagram and everywhere else you can
follow me at timcast do you guys want to
shout out your whatevers yeah kriscar17
on twitter i'll see you all there yeah
if you want to support me you can very
easily on luke uncensored dot com i just
released a free video giving you a sneak
peek at the value that i try to give you
i also have three master classes there
about expatting survival journalism
whatever you're interested in i try to
provide you that value
lookuncensored.com hope to see some of
you guys there thanks for having me
great night guys good week have a nice
uh weekend and enjoy your yourself and
and the calmness around you let it let
it flow uh chris good to see you man
yeah thanks for coming in
congratulations yes oh thank you thank
you very much congratulations
the new boy a new car new car in the
family yeah
he's keeping you up all night yeah he's
laughing hey and the book behind you i
don't think anyone's mentioned that yet
that's not your book but that is the
inverted world is that the first or the
second first that is the first volume
and chris editor of this book uh by the
uh estimable shane cashman who did some
incredible journalistic work on this
yeah we're very proud of that and i hear
it's still number one in certain
categories invertedworldbook.com
that's exciting well you can follow me
at iancrossline.net and i will see you
guys next week
thank you guys so much for tuning in i
did want to say as well uh that somebody
was asking me if they could get this
shirt they said they'd get this shirt if
they could get any color other than
quote banana yellow all right fine there
should be a bunch of colors about the
yellow there are tons of colors on the
site we have like how many colors
there's like seven yeah there's there's
so many so yes go to the site check it
out get your own step on snake shirt
they're amazing they're wonderful
they're comfortable i'm hoping this one
holds up well you guys may follow me on
twitter at sour patch links when we
leave tonight can we go to the wide shot
well yes but let me let me let me just
say and um you can go to the white chat
right now i'll just wrap up with this
sure uh i i noticed this don't think i
didn't notice this that someone in the
chat said i would ruin tim in magic the
gathering oh oh this is false this is
going to be fun
[Laughter]
let's bring a partner i've got
stupid decks edh decks that are like
turn one win in the most ridiculous and
insane ways like it's no joke that ian
and i have decks that are so insane that
whoever goes first basically wins and we
know it
it's like oh you want you won you get
the mana crypt you go you got the soul
ring oh it's just high cards i'm gonna
make nine man yeah oh i love that kai
kardashian yeah that's so good just mass
producing mana and then i'm like all
right i'm gonna you know draw out your
deck and like it's too it sucks is you
gotta go after tim first or he'll win
and then he gets mad and then he's like
why are you coming at me first and
you're like i get mad because like
you're gonna when we're playing
multiplayer even when i'm losing and
like i'm just i'm like i'm like okay
guys i'm gonna play a weaker deck just
to have fun ian goes now's my chance to
destroy him and i'm like come on i would
have been doing that since we were 14
too
all right everybody thanks for hanging
out we will see you all uh on monday or
go to youtube.com
castle check out the vlog we'll see you
there
you